. Herzlich willkommen zum Podcast-Rudel, meine Damen und Herren. Stefan Tietze ist heute bei uns. Ja, Tietze. Wir haben heute schon gehört, gerade eben, wir haben einen Gast. Und wir sind sehr stolz auf diesen Gast. Wir wollen ja tatsächlich seit zehn Folgen, glaube ich, bei Folge zehn wollten wir das erste Mal einen Gast einladen. Wir haben es tatsächlich nie geschafft, weil niemand Bock hatte, bei uns mitzumachen. Aber heute, endlich hat es tatsächlich mal funktioniert. Und ich glaube, ich höre mal ganz kurz, ist er bereit? Okay, er ist bereit. Du könntest reinkommen. Hier ist er! Herzlich willkommen im Podcast-UFO! Olli P! Einen wunderschönen guten Abend. Ja, schön, dass ich hier sein darf bei euch. Und da komme ich dreimal. Ja, wuhu! Herzlich willkommen Ollikommen Olli P, Mensch, der Peter Fox, der das kleinen Mann ist, wie man es ja auch so sagt. Ja, so sagt man das. Danke für die Einladung, wir probieren es ja schon seit ein paar Wochen, aber irgendwie hatten wir alle immer irgendwas. Wir dachten, es ist ja nur normal, dass du absagst. Stimmt überhaupt nicht, nein, eigentlich hätte ich nie kommen, ja stimmt auch wieder. Ich wollte immer kommen, aber es war mir auch ganz, ganz unangenehm, dass es immer nicht einmal war Olli-Schulz-Konzert, einmal... Das ist ein sehr guter, da waren wir auch, da waren wir auch. Wir haben dich tatsächlich auch gesehen, wir haben uns nicht trautig anzusprechen. Sag mal, was ist denn mit euch das eigentlich? Naja, aber du halt, also abseits, du sass. Ja. Als einziger auf dem Konzert, er sass IP. Nein, hinter mir sass noch ein Arbeitskollege von euch plus euer Chef, also die sassen dann auch dort. Ja, du sass, alles stand, nur du sass, was sich jetzt als einzigen cool oder als einzigen uncool macht. Ich habe Rückenprobleme. Das schon seit Stunden. Nee, wirklich. Olli Schulz auch und er machte auch die Bühne. Ach nee, ich passe aber gut auf dem Olli Schulz-Konzert, glaube ich, so ein bisschen. Da hat jeder Rückenprobleme auch. Also ich hätte es auch gut gefunden, da hätten sich alle hingesetzt, weil die Stimmung war auch so, als ob alle sitzen würden. Es sind aber auch nicht die Songs, wo man jetzt so aufspringt und dann so mitklappt. Nee, das nicht, aber ich habe so gehört, ich habe mir gewünscht, dass wenn man zu so einem Konzert geht, dass alle anderen, er kommt auf die Bühne, dass alle trotzdem ausrasten und warum immer. Aber irgendwie war das so, weil er auch erzählt hatte bei sanft und sorgfältig, ja und geile Stimmung und die waren nicht so geil, wo du stehst du in Köln und alle, okay. Aber im Nachhinein ist gesagt, dass die Stimmung da jetzt eher verhalten war. Ja genau, ruhig. Aber die Hörte finden es trotzdem gut, es ist ja nicht so, dass die Leute sagen, das war kacke, aber ich glaube, das ist halt so ein anderes Happening, dass man einfach froh ist dabei gewesen zu sein. Es ist vor allem auch so eine Mischung aus Comedy, Stand-up und Musik ja auch, wenn man auch mal hören will, was da sehr erachtet und auch die Geschichten dazwischen geil sind. Was das erste Mal ist, dass jemand über ein Publikum gesprochen hat, von dem ich teil war. Das ist mir noch nie passiert, dass jemand über ein Publikum gesprochen hat und ich wusste, ich bin ja dabei und ich habe das als indirekte Beleidigung empfunden, also so ein bisschen als, ja, war eher so ein bisschen ruhigeres Verhalten des Publikums.
Ich meinte, ja fick dich, Alter, was willst du denn so? Das war, wo ich mir dachte...
Was ich jetzt gerade gesagt habe. Also das heißt, weil ich jetzt gerade gesagt habe, das Publikum war ruhig und jetzt hast du gesagt, daraufhin...
Ach genau. Was war denn dein...
Du bist auch, also Florentin muss man dazu sagen, er war der schlechteste Zuhörer, den ich hier auf dem Konzert gesehen habe.
Mein Gott, ey, wie ich das schon wieder hasse.
Nein, es war so. Ich stand daneben, wollte Stimmung machen, weil ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin jetzt ein Teil dieses Publikums, wo er im Nachhinein darüber sagen kann, boah, das war das beste Publikum, was ich je gesehen habe, und dann gebe ich dementsprechend Gas und du standst da und hast halt geweint, weil die Songs sich so berührt haben. Ja, aber was ich immer ganz schlimm finde in solchen sozialen Situationen, wo man irgendwie Unterhaltung konsumiert mit anderen Leuten, dann finde ich, ist da viel so Aufgesetztheit dabei, so man tanzt dann mit mit, man zeigt, man ist total in der Musik drin und so.
Das liegen 40 Partys, wenn alle schon um 20 Uhr anfangen zu tanzen. Genau, ich habe das Gefühl, da ist es relativ wenig authentisch und ich habe dann immer selber Angst, die Musik zu genießen, weil ich Angst habe, vor anderen als aufgesetzt rüber zu kommen, sondern irgendwie wuuu und mitzusingen und hier und da, da fühle ich mich immer total beobachtet sozial. Aber ich, Aber es ist ja wirklich eher eine Sache oder ein Event gewesen, was man auch so wie man ihn sonst eigentlich auch dann wahrnimmt oder wie ich ihn wahrnehme, einfach zuhörend und das einfach gutfindend und einfach dauer schmunzelnd. Ja, ich habe alle fanden das geil, ich habe auch alle, für alle war das ein riesen geiler Abend und im Endeffekt haben die halt, sind ja nicht ausgerastet, aber ich glaube, ich weiß auch nicht, warum es in anderen Städten anders ist, finde ich auch immer ganz interessant, dass dass er von anderen Städten erzählt, dass sie ja mega ausgerastet sind. Wir waren ja nicht da, vielleicht war es überall genauso wie ein Pöl. Bistwahrscheinlich, ja. Hattest du mal ein Publikum, das so überhaupt gar nicht mitgemacht hat? Nein. Gut, nächste Frage. Comedy, bam, bam, bam, bam! Also ich kann, nee, weiß ich nicht. Also, nee, kann ich mich, nee. Eigentlich immer alles gut gewesen bis jetzt. Letztes Mal war lustig, da ist meine Jeans gerissen, weil ich bin nach unten gesprungen ins Publikum, abgeklatscht nach oben und alle sind sich am Feuer. Mit Security abgeklatscht oder was? Oder mit wem? Nee, nicht mit den Leuten, die im, ihr Schweine. Mit der eigenen Mutter. Hey, schau was ihr da, wir fahren gleich los, noch zwei Songs. Genau, geh schon mal ins Auto und lass schon mal das Auto hören, ja. Nee, aber ich bin die Hose gerissen, das war eigentlich noch so ... Weil wir auf die Bühne gehen wieder, als das alle gesehen haben. Ich hab auf der Bühne auch die Hose gewechselt, weil ich dachte, dann wäre ich schon dann schon. Ach so, sehr gut, das ist sehr gut. Ich habe auch gehört, dass der Sänger von ACDC, der hat ja irgendwann, Angus Young, der hat ja irgendwann angefangen, auf der Bühne so Kreisel zu drehen, auf dem Boden und so sich hinzulegen. Aber warum? Dass er das nur gemacht hat, weil er anfangs irgendwann hingefallen ist.
Das war peinlich, wollte er überspielen im Moment und deswegen hat er angefangen,
auf dem Boden irgendwie Breakdown-Scheize zu machen.
Der Rest des Konzerts einfach liegen zu bestreiten.
Ja, aber das ist eine supergeile Idee.
Das ist eine richtig gute Idee, einfach das Überspielen.
Vielleicht auch nicht.
Wart ihr bei diesem Olli-P-Konzert? Schreibt uns in die Kommentare, wie es tatsächlich war.
Hat er mit mir wirklich abgeklatscht?
Habt ihr alles gesehen? Schlagerstadel am Bodensee vor drei Wochen, also wenn das hier ausgestrahlt wird, vor sieben Wochen. Nächste Frage, komm, ich bin aufgeregt. Okay, wir haben wahnsinnig viele Fragen. Du bist ja, sag ich mal, jetzt, äh, du bist ja ein Künstler, der jetzt, sag ich mal, weitestens ... Künstler ist ja auch ein weit dehnbarer Begriff. Ja, ich verstehe auch Stefan als Künstler. Oh, das freut mich aber jetzt auch.
Deswegen möchte ich auch gleich mal...
Hey, jetzt kann ich alles machen.
Jetzt kann ich alles machen.
Du bist ja ein Künstler, der im weitesten Sinne für die Aeronautik bekannt ist.
Im weitesten Sinne. Jetzt hast du es natürlich relativ schwer.
In den letzten Wochen ist ja das eine oder andere passiert.
Ich distanziere mich von dieser Frage.
Wie ist da dein Bauchgefühl? Oh, das ist furchtbar. So, warte mal, also ihr habt gar keinen Booster da. Ich habe jetzt vor allem auch sehr gut was mitgebracht, und zwar ich habe Bananen dabei. Oh! Hey, das ist das Beste, was man gerade haben kann. Ja, das sind echte Bananen. Ganz viele, ja, sind sehr braun, aber da sind sie süsser. Und ich habe viele Freunde, die bei einer ganz bestimmten Fluglinie arbeiten. Und dann habe ich noch Wasser mitgebracht und ich habe noch einen Apfel, wenn ihr wollt. Und jetzt kommt es, es ist Mango-Konfekt, nur mit Agavensirup gesündet. Ja, er hat Mangos mitgebracht, dankeschön! Es ist so wie Booster, nur ganz anders. Oh mein Gott, es ist vegan. Ja, das ist total geil. Wie gut ist das denn? Ich ernähre mich nämlich seit Karneval aus Versehen alkoholfrei, zuckerfrei, getreidefrei und ... Mit Agaven-Sirup ist Agaven-Dicksaft, nicht auch dieses Zucker-Alternativmittel. Keiner weiss es so genau. Keiner weiss es genau, aber es klingt auf jeden Fall ... Ich probier mal eine, okay? Hab ich schon länger, aber es ist noch fast voll. Ab schon 1999, aber es ist mal einfach ... Ich auch ein, vielen Dank. Kommen da Erinnerungen wieder hoch? Getrocknete Mangos? Ist das so ein Ding? Es ist immer so ein bisschen das Gefühl, esse ich jetzt noch eins davon, in der Hoffnung, dass man den Geschmack dann nicht mehr so richtig wahrnimmt. Das frische Mango mag ich gar nicht zum Beispiel. Ich finde auch, der erste bisschen bei sowas ist immer ein bisschen Überwindung und danach geht's. Aber sehr gut, auch vom ersten bisschen an. Komm, nächste Frage. Vielen Dank, vielen Dank. Die letzte war ja eher spontan von dir gestellt, die ich da vorhin schon überlegt habe. Ich distanziere mich davon. Stefan, mach du mal eine gute Frage, komm. Wo hast du das T-Shirt her? In Klammern Bedingung, er trägt ein T-Shirt. Okay, also ich habe ein Sweatshirt an. Ich stelle diese Frage hinten an. Ja, mach das mal bitte. Aber ich habe, na egal. Hast du Haustiere? Ja. Okay. Wir sind gerne gut. Nenke Frage, was ist die Hauptstadt von Island? Istanbul. Sehr gut, sehr gut, vielen Dank. Sehr gut. Ich habe mir heute einen Apfel geholt tatsächlich, weil wir haben ja so ein bisschen auf dich gewartet hier vorne. Und es ist ja schon so ein bisschen so ein... Ihr habt auf mich gewartet, weil ich zehn Minuten vor der Zeit da war, wo wir uns verabredet hatten. Er hat trotzdem auf dich gewartet, wir haben den ganzen Tag schon total aufgeregt. Wir haben den ganzen Tag aufgeregt. Ihr habt sogar hier gezeltet, obwohl ja auch hier arbeiten. Ja, natürlich. Wir sind nur seit zehn Tagen. Warum wir das auch? So ist die Aufnahmesituation. Tuch da gar nicht. Aber ich habe mir extra einen Apfel geholt, weil es ist gut, mit einem Apfel zu warten, habe ich gemerkt. Also ein Tipp, falls ihr mal auf jemanden wartet, holt euch einen Apfel, das ist einfach eine super Situation. Das sieht auch richtig cool aus. Ja, man hat was zu tun eigentlich als so. Apfel. Entweder rauchen Abfell. Abfell, Abfell, Abfell, Abfell. In den meisten Filmen ist es ja so, dass der Bösewicht immer einen Apfel hat, dass es so ein Zeichen ist, er ist ein Arschloch, er isst ein Apfel, ist ja auch ein Zeichen von Respektlosigkeit. Nehmen wir mal drei, nehmen wir mal bitte. Ja, ist aber tatsächlich so, ich weiss nicht, warum sich... Überhaupt gar nicht. Na ja, gut, wenn der Bösewicht... Der Gute schneidet es sich mit seinem Messer und sitzt auf einer Klippe und guckt übers Meer, der Böse, der beißt so rein und schmeisst den Apfelgrieb.
Schmeißt den hinterher.
Der Böse macht den Grieb bei. Ganz kurz, drei Apfel-essende Bösewichte bitte in Filmen. Man muss sich mal hinterfragen, weil manchmal ist das Quatsch, was er erzählt. Und der Nummer eins. Michael Bay, hier 2012, Roland Emmerich, da hat der Bösewicht auch immer einen Apfel in der Hand. Einige ...
Er ist der böse Wicht in 2002.
Die Natur, einige, einige James Bond, ist der Apfel. Aber wir wollen jetzt auch gar nicht so diskriminieren, lass uns nicht. Nein, das stimmt schon, aber nein, es ist ja wichtig, dass man einen Bösewicht so zeichnet, dass er Dinge nur nebenbei macht. James Bond kommt in die böse Festung und der Bösewicht aus James Bond, dem ist das völlig egal, dass er jetzt plötzlich seinen Erzfeind gegenübersteht. Deswegen ist er ein Apfel oder er streichelt eine Katze, das sind alles Symbole dafür, dass nicht seine vollständige Aufmerksamkeit mein Problem ist, weil er so ein fucking Werner ist. Deswegen wird der Gute auch nie direkt einfach erschossen, sondern es wird doch der ganze Plan erzählt. Genau. Und ja, genau. Der Bösewicht erhebt sich. Auch da nicht erschossen, sondern noch der Mechanismus, der vier Tage dauert und dann ist die Batterie alle und er ist frei. Genau, weil sich der Bösewicht dadurch erhebt, dass er nicht den vollen Respekt dem Gegner gegenüberbringt, sondern dass er die Sachen noch nebenbei macht. Und das liebe ich übrigens so sehr auch am Podcast UFO, dass man sich einfach über Sachen unterhält und auch merkt, dass auch andere Leute sich, ich will jetzt nicht sagen unnütze Gedanken, aber Gedanken über Themen macht, was man jetzt normalerweise nicht ausdrücken würde. Aber ich finde das gut und ich finde es gut, also einfach, ihr habt immer ganz viele Themen, ich weiß nicht, ob das immer spontan ist, aber wo so eure Beobachtungen mit dabei sind, wo ich so denke, ey, ganz einfach tolle Anrichten. Geht da mal noch ein bisschen näher drauf ein. Ja, also und zwar, ihr habt auch ein tolles Equipment, wie möchte ich mal sagen. Das hört sich jetzt auch, obwohl ich es nicht selber höre, kann ich mir vorstellen, dass es jetzt schon viel besser sich anhört, als auch in den ersten Folgen, wo ihr den Zuhörern gesagt habt, dass es nicht stimmt, dass es zu leise war, aber es war zu leise. Wir waren sehr arrogant, haben gehofft, dass es nicht an uns liegt, sondern an den Kopfhörern der anderen, in der Hoffnung, wir haben ja auch sehr viel Geld kriegen von Sony und so, in der Hoffnung, dass sich bessere Kopfhörer kaufen, hat alles nicht funktioniert. Aber wir müssen dazu sagen, das ist die Mani-Prinzip. Das ist die Mani-Prinzip, genau. Aber da haben wir sehr viel von gelernt, das ist unser großer Tutor. Aber wir haben ja gerade sitzen wir in einem Studio, zum ersten Mal in einer professionellen Tonkabine, naja, wir haben schon mal, naja, gut, aber wir haben wirklich sitzen wir zum ersten Mal in einer richtig guten Tonkabine, die wirklich gross genug ist für drei Leute zum Aufnehmen und es ist wirklich, also wenn der Sound heute nicht perfekt ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht. Es ist wichtig, dass wir ja nicht in einer Tonkabine sitzen, wie es normalerweise ist, weil wir sind eigentlich in einem Aufnahmeraum.
Ja, wir sind in einer Tonregie. Wir sind in einer fucking Tonregie von einem Studio im Fernsehen. Dass ich es mal hier hinschaffe, hätte ich nie gedacht. Und Olli hat das beste Mikrofon tatsächlich von uns drei. Das stimmt. Aber das Mikrofon wird auch noch von anderen Menschen benutzt. Darf man das sagen oder darf man das nicht sagen? Ja, das darf man voll sagen. Kannst du es gerne sagen, wenn du möchtest. Es ist von William Cohn. Es ist von William Cohn. Es ist unglaublich. Es riecht auch ein bisschen, muss ich sagen, also die, seine Aura ist hier noch spürbar. Die ist noch spürbar. Bisschen noch nach Ei, als ob er noch nicht ganz geschlüpft wäre. Ein bisschen ein alter Mann, aber das muss so sein. Aber ich glaube ja, das habe ich eben schon gemacht, den Gag, er kam eben schon nicht so gut an, ich sage ihn trotzdem nochmal, ich glaube, dass William nur durch das Mikro so klingt. Und nicht, weil er wirklich so eine gute Stimme hat. In Wirklichkeit hat er eine sehr hohe Fistelstimme, weil so klingt er jetzt perfekt. Sehr guter Gag. Ist auch nicht wirklich ein Gag. Apropos Gag, ich möchte mal ganz kurz nochmal auf unsere Community eingehen. Ich war heute auf einer Beerdigung. Ey, da lacht man nicht. Also, falls ihr euch fragt, warum Olli so wahnsinnig gut drauf ist. Aber hast du da auch Fly für dein neues Konzert verteilt? Also die Sandwich-Bar ist schon ein Lassstopp, jetzt schon.
Okay, aber der Tod hat auch nichts mit dein neues Konzert verteilt? Also wie, massisch PR-mäßig. Das ist schon ein Lassstopp, jetzt schon. Okay. Aber der Tod hat auch nichts mit deinem Konzert zu tun, oder? Der Tod? Nein, ich glaube nicht. Also, nee, bis jetzt nicht. Das ist alles unabhängig voneinander. Aber es war ein wahnsinnig erfolgreichen, tollen, krassen Tag, wo Dinge passiert sind, ohne dass es geplant war. Und deswegen bin ich wirklich total gut gelaunt, weil der ganze Tag heute einfach Wahnsinn war, sowohl tief traurig bei der Beerdigung, also wirklich, obwohl es kein Verwandter war, habe ich noch nie so viel geweint. Also ich habe beim Tod meiner Oma und bei anderen viel weniger geweint als heute. Ich weiß nicht, woran das lag, ob es die generelle Stimmung von allen Trauergästen war, ob es andere Umstände sind, weil ich jetzt halt älter bin und anders. Vielleicht hat man auch lange nicht mehr geweint und irgendwann muss dann einfach sehr viel raus. Ich weine immer auf der Bühne, immer nach jedem Lied weine ich, wenn die Leute klatschen. Glaubst du, dass es so, dass wenn man länger nicht weint, dass man dann wieder weint? Ich glaube schon. Es ist wie so ein Samenstau. Es ist wie Samenstau, man muss halt sehr viel, sehr schnell raus. Ich habe auch gehört, dass auch die Samen dann auch raus, wenn man auch jetzt wiederum nicht ornaniert hat und dann weint, dass die auch durch die Augen rauskommt. Dann muss muss es auch durch die Augen raus, dann brennt es etwas, aber das ist okay, das muss man erst aushalten. Das heißt, man hat dann irgendwann auch einen feuchten Traum weinen und schlafen. Männer zum Beispiel mit sehr grossen Tränensäcken, weiss man, die haben lange nicht mehr geweint. Richtig. Und wenn man denen mal einen Gefallen tun sollte, sollte man die vielleicht mal ein bisschen anstacheln, damit die mal weinen. Wenn man sie aber so unscharf sieht, dass sie so schlieren vor den Augen hat, dann ist es meistens auch, dass es so wie ein feuchter Tropfen halt nur für die Augen. Genau, richtig. Ich war mal in einer Musikschule und da war es immer so, dass bevor man in den Unterrichtsraum konnte, in so einem Warteraum gewartet hat, wo noch andere Musikschüler waren, von noch anderen Instrumenten. Und dann habe ich zwei Violinschülerinnen, die ein ganzes Stück jünger waren als ich. Zum Weinen gebracht. Die waren irgendwie gerade zu Anfang Pubertät und haben sich gerade so interessiert, für den männlichen Körper zu interessieren und alles. Und ich habe dann immer da so ein Magazin gelesen und habe gehört, wie die anderen sich unterhalten haben. Da kamst du vorbei und die haben sich nicht mehr für männliche Körper interessiert. Genau, genau. In dem Moment wurden sie lesbisch, ja, instant. Aber schlag eigentlich sofort. Und dann habe ich sie tatsächlich überhört, wie sie dann geredet haben und dann haben sie gesagt, ja, es ist ja immer so eine Sache mit dem, mit dem Jungen und dem, und der Grösse des Penis. Und woran man herausfinden kann, wie gross der Penis eines Jungs ist, ist, wie lange... Um die Hose runterzuziehen und abzumessen? Genau, die Strategie habe ich dann verfolgt. Das ist die Mente, die Metermassen sagen. Das ist meistens richtig. Genau, nee, und dann haben sie gesagt, und zwar kann man es daran feststellen, wie lange der Junge auf dem Klo braucht. Ach so stimmt, weil der Urin ja viel länger braucht, um durch den Körper auszukommen. Ja, und vor allem, je länger der Junge braucht. Ich würde zustimmen, mit einer sehr, sehr genauen Stoppuhr, so auf die Tausendstelle Sekunde, würde ich dem zustimmen. Also ich kenne die genaue Umrechnungstabelle nicht, aber sie haben auf jeden Fall gesagt, ja, je länger der Junge pinkeln muss, desto größer ist er ein Penis. Und dann habe ich ein paar Minuten gewartet und bin natürlich aufs Klo gegangen und habe noch mal so zehn Minuten drangehängt und in der Kabine gewartet, bin zurückgelaufen mit dem motherfucking badass Auftritt mit den grossen Augen. Das war schon so ein Highlight meiner Jugend, wo ich mir dachte, geil, einmal den Moment, dass Mädchen gegenüber von mir denken, ich hätte einen grossen Penis. Das glaube ich, habe ich nie wieder. Aber wieso wissen jetzt die Frauen mit der Violine oder die Mädchen, dass du gebuddert hast, vielleicht hätten sie auch gedacht, dass du einfach gross gemacht hast und dass es deswegen so lange gedauert hatte. Und dass es dich deswegen so angeschaut hat. Ja, ja. Das war keine Bewunderung, es war Hass, es war auch Hass einfach. Ein bisschen furcht, da jetzt auch drauf zu gehen vielleicht, absolut. Aber lass uns noch mal bei dem Thema Beerdigung bleiben, finde ich ein super Thema für eine Comedy-Sendung. Oder Was darf Satire, finde ich auch immer. Was darf Satire, stellen wir mal hin. Warum muss ich immer die Scheiss-Szenen anreißen, wenn da ein Klinger drauf ein ist. Wenn nicht sagen, dass alles, was wir heute sagen, dass es Satire ist. Das ist okay, das ist okay, und das wollen die Leute auch hören. Ganz kurz, es ist alles Satire, was wir sagen. Es ist was ganz Natürliches. Gibt es auch satirische Hooligans und satirische Bengalos, weil dann kann man sagen, ja, das ist eher sozial kritisch und anprangend gemeint. Ich glaube, vieles ist auch satirisch gemeint, weil Leute haben zufindig Erfahrung im Thema-Bereich Comedy, dass sie es nicht rüberbringen können. Also es ist wirklich in Wirklichkeit ein Weltkrieg anfangen, weil es einfach lustig ist, weil es ein guter Gag ist. Oder es war eine versteckte Kamera und irgendwann hat ZDF zurückgebaut und hat gesagt, all das kriegen wir niemandem vermittelt. Wo seid ihr? Ich greife Hohel lang. Wo fucking seid ihr? Ja, die Kamera war aus. Da ist die Kamera. Da ist keine Kamera. Aber warum interessiert dich das Thema? Warum willst du darüber reden, wie weit Satire gehen darf? Warum ist das ein Problem für dich? Nicht Problem, nee, generell einfach, weil das auch die Gefahr birgt, dass jemand etwas wirklich ernst meint und komplett abledert und sich einfach nur schützt, indem er danach sagt, das war ja gar nicht so gemein, das war nur Satire. Hast du ein gutes Beispiel? Nee, generell, das ist mir einfach nur heute darauf bezogen, dass ich weiß, dass ich jetzt etwas in einem Mikrofon sage. Ah, okay, du willst dich absichern, ich verstehe schon. Ja, so ein bisschen absichern. Ah, okay, du willst wissen, wie man dich absichern kann. Im Endeffekt alles Satire. Ja, genau. Nee, aber trotzdem, wer entscheidet denn das, wer Satire machen darf? Kann man auch sagen, ich bin Comedian, aber vielleicht bist du gar kein Comedian oder wer entscheidet denn das? Man kann auch von sich selber behaupten, ich bin Comedian. Ich glaube auch wirklich, und scheiss, manche Comedians, ich will jetzt keine Namen nennen, aber habe ich das Gefühl, dass die einfach nur provozieren wollen und die einfach mit diesem Stempel, den sie sich selber aufgedrückt haben, ich bin Comedian, können sie Gesundheit, oh mein Gott, es war fast perfekt, was ich eben, und dass sie einfach mit diesem Stempel, den sie sich selber aufgedrückt haben, einfach provokante Scheisse raushauen wollen, so antisemitische Scheisse und dann am Ende sagen, sie wären Comedians einfach und dann vielleicht zum Beispiel, möchte ich jetzt vielleicht keinen Namen nennen, oh, doch Satire, was ich mache. Oh, du hast noch was in deinem Jutebeutel. Ja, Taschentücher. Okay. Ja, also ich bin ja immer der Meinung, dass Comedy alles darf. Ich bin ja immer ganz boring, weil ich dann eine relativ straighte Meinung habe. Wobei du auch ganz oft auch mal drüber umgeschrieben gestreichtst, das wird ja wohl immer sein. Nee, das ist ja auch richtig, also finde ich ja auch, dass es so ist. Und ich finde ja auch gerade das, was ihr macht oder woran auch ihr Mitarbeitet, dass es auch sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr viel dazu beiträgt, dass das auch endlich mal … Kannst du da noch mal ein bisschen drauf eingehen? Ja, also ich finde … Nein, das möchte ich euch lieber privat sagen. Das ist nicht. Nee, aber ist ja wirklich so, da wird ja ganz viel aufgebrochen und einfach ganz viel gemacht, was in anderen Ländern wahrscheinlich schon seit Jahrzehnten der Fall ist, dass man das einfach so macht, dass man aber gerade in Deutschland sich meistens nicht traut, weil man denkt, man darf es nicht. Ja, das ist wenig. Ja, vor allem, also ich meine, es gibt ja in Deutschland auch nicht so diesen Modus, wo man alles darf. Also ich habe letztens den The Roast of Justin Bieber gesehen, wo sich dann ein paar gute Freunde von Justin Bieber treffen und im Fernsehen ihn einfach fertig machen und sich über ihn lustig machen und jede charakterliche kleinste Schwäche ausreizen und wirklich die heftigsten, rassistischen, sexistischen, widerlichsten Witze machen, die es überhaupt gibt. Und ich finde es einfach geil, dass es diese Plattform in Amerika gibt und diesen Modus gibt. In Deutschland gibt es das nämlich wirklich so nicht. Überhaupt nicht. Undenkbar. Es war vor sechs oder sieben Jahren, war ich zu Gast auf dem Comedypreis und da hatte sich, weil geehrt wurde, Hugo Egon Balder und er hatte sich einen Roast gewünscht. Problem war, keiner in Deutschland wusste zu diesem Zeitpunkt, was ein Roast ist. Ein Roast ist. Und es kamen dann fünf andere Comedians, die seinen Roast von einem Promter abgelesen haben und das Publikum … warte mal ganz kurz, ich zeige euch das Geräusch … Welcome to Germany. Warte, ich habe das Geräusch, die mich damals aufgenommen hat. Das ist jetzt ein Foto. Was ich gemacht habe. Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, warte. Handy, warte. Tut mir leid. Schneiden wir alles raus. Schnellen wir raus.. Schneiden wir sowieso nicht raus, ihr habt noch nie was rausgeschnitten, wo ihr gesagt habt, wir schneiden jetzt raus. Und zwar, dieses Geräusch, die Roast war zu Ende und es klang so. Ja, es ist aber wirklich so, weil ich glaube, die Deutschen kommen ein Problem damit, fertig gemacht zu werden, mit Selbstironie haben die Leute ein Problem. Und wenn jemand dann sagt, wie Jan zum Beispiel, der Böhmer, der herkommt, eine Selbstironie an den Tag. Das ist für die Mindblowing für Deutsche einfach. Das ist halt so ein Ding. Aber ich glaube, das Problem ist auch gar nicht, dass es viele Leute wirklich selber stört, sondern dass sie das Gefühl haben, sie müssten sich jetzt aufregen, um auf jeden Fall als aufrichtiger, moralischer Mensch dazustehen. Das heißt, wenn jemand sich über Schwarze lustig macht, auch wenn es einen selber überhaupt nicht stört, muss man sagen, nein, das darf man nicht, weil man eben als Toleranter die anderen einschliessenden Mensch dastehen will. Das heißt, glaube ich, es ist gar kein Problem erster Ordnung, sondern nur der zweiten Ordnung, dass man sich irgendwie darstellen möchte und es zum guten Ton gehört, sich aufzuregen, und das darf man doch nicht. Und das finde ich einfach furchtbar. Und ich finde es eben cool, dass es in der amerikanischen Entertainmentkultur zumindest diesen Modus gibt. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass die jeden Tag über die Straße laufen und sich über jeden Nigger sagen und irgendwie die härtesten Witze reißen, aber es gibt zumindest diesen theoretischen Ort, an dem man alles darf. Und die Frage ist halt nur, wie weit breitet sich der aus und wie weit darf man da kommen? Und inwieweit kommen da auch Leute rein, die das ausnutzen, weil sie halt doch eigentlich andere Meinungen haben, aber halt diesen Deckmantel, der kann man die nutzen, um andere ein Fech zu machen. Ja, aber die sind nicht lustig. Solange die lustig sind, ist das auch okay.
Apropos, ich hatte mit Olli Pocher vor zehn Jahren mal eine Sendung auf ProSieben Gameshow-Marathon und wir hatten beim Warm-Up haben wir das so gemacht, dass wir gegenseitig uns und unsere Familie gegenseitig gerostet haben. Das hatte aber auch damals komplett niemand verstanden und wir haben echt die heftigsten Sachen gesagt, die man sich gegenseitig sagen kann und wir haben uns bepisst vor Lachen, aber wir waren auch ziemlich die Einzigen. Als Warm-up für ein Publikum glaube ich richtig gut. Das war ja ein cooles Dauer. Am Ende waren alle sauer auf euch und haben keinen Bock auf die Sendung gehabt. Genau, deswegen wurde sie auch abgesetzt. Das Warm-up war super, leider wird das nicht ausgestrahlt. Vielleicht wäre das nicht abgesetzt worden, Vielleicht würde das immer noch laufen, das Warm-up an sich. Vielleicht läuft das auch parallel. Keine Ahnung. Vielleicht läuft das auch nur noch. Auf ein Festes oder so, wo niemand das mitbekommt. Ich glaube, wenn wir eine Sendung hätten, haben wir schon eine Sendung auf... Das heißt, wir haben sie selber nur noch nicht gesehen. Wir haben sie noch nicht gefunden. Wurde ist so schlecht, wir haben sie noch nicht gesehen. Gibt es denn Warm-up beim Neo-Magazin? Wird Warm-up gemacht? Ja, also Jan macht selber. Jan macht selber. Er erzählt immer Geschichten. Also Warm-up ist, wenn man vor einer Fernsehaufzeichnung, bevor die Kameras aufbieten laufen, kommt der Moderator oder ein Warm-upper nochmal vor das Publikum, erzählt Witze, holt ein paar Applaus ein, damit die Kameras die Leute finden können, wie sie applaudieren, weil sonst zeigen die Kameras ja das Studio. Und das ist das Warm-up. Also könnt ihr euch mal anschauen, wenn ihr zu einer Aufzeichnung mitzunehmen seid. Wer zuhause etwas im Fernsehen schaut, wo Publikum applaudiert, es war nie aufgrund einer Pointe oder einer Aktion, die im Studio passiert ist, sondern alles davor. Und wenn ihr euch nicht erklären könnt, warum lachen so viele Leute über diesen schlechten Gags, es war nicht dieser schlechte Gag, über den sie wirklich gelacht haben. Es war ein anderer Gag und dann wurde der Lacher verschoben. Ein bisschen die Magie von Fernsehen zerstören, ja. Dafür sind wir da. Hast du mitgezählt, wie viele deiner Sendungen abgesetzt wurden? Ach, so ziemlich alle. Schätz mal, wie viele ungefähr? Acht oder neun. Ist das auch irgendwann egal? Das ist nicht schlecht. Das hat doch nichts mit mir selber zu tun, auch wenn es immer mir passiert. Aber reagiert man am Ende irgendwie so nüchterner darauf? Ja, das ist am Anfang. Man macht sich ja am Anfang schon immer, ich mach mir trotzdem zwar immer Gedanken und probier mir alles durchzugrübeln und zu reflektieren, aber irgendwann, du kannst ja nichts daran ändern und ich sag mal auch, es kann ja auch sein, das habe ich ja auch schon von vielen Sachen, die ich im Fernsehen gesehen habe, die ich unfassbar gut fand und die werden dann abgesetzt und es gibt halt mega viel Scheisse, wie wir wissen, was die ganze Zeit im Fernsehen läuft und es wird nicht abgesetzt. Also auch das Abgesetztwerden einer Sendung hat nicht unbedingt was mit Qualität zu tun.
Eigentlich ist es schon geil, wenn es abgesetzt wird.
Ritterschlag.
Genau, es ist eher ein Ritterschlag.
Und von daher muss ich sagen, bin ich schon Hand of the King.
Man sagt ja auch, Quote haben die anderen.
Das ist der erste tolle Spruch.
Der zweite ist, dass Quote ja quasi kein Merkmal für Qualität ist.
Das ist auch richtig, genau.
Und das beides ergibt zusammen halt ein Bild, was wir alle richtigerweise vom Fernsehen haben. Dankeschön. Ich wollte noch kurz auf etwas anderes eingehen, und zwar Situationen, in denen man als Deutscher keine Comedy benutzt, aber vielleicht sollte. Also haben wir eben schon angesprochen, aber das ist ein Tiefwort Beerdigungen. Ja. Wie wäre es denn einfach, wenn man eine lustige Beerdigung macht? Wo man den Leuten sagt, habt doch alle auf einer Beerdigung Partyhüte auf und ein bisschen glaubt, wird es funktionieren oder wird es nicht funktionieren, weil Beerdigung halt an sich was sehr trauriges ist.
Das kommt halt auf die Familie, auf den Trauergrat, auf das Umfeld an. Es gibt ja auch die Sachen wie hier der Walker-Dings von, oder irgendeiner aus Amerika, der gestorben ist, da hat dann auch die Frau am Strand gefeiert mit allen Freunden und so. Wies ich nicht. Allein leider war das schon wieder der Anlass für mich, der war echt witzig. Der war echt witzig. Ja, ist ja auch gut. Eigentlich lieben wir ihn. Ja, er ist wirklich gut, er ist nur nicht von ihm. Ich mag auch eure, wollen wir auf Twitter zu sprechen kommen? Na, auf gar keinen Fall. Okay. Ui, wir haben ein paar Leute gesagt, macht nie wieder diese Kommentare scheiße bei Twitter. Okay. Wir haben mal angefangen, Leute zu kommentieren. Wir können nicht bei Twitter reden. Ach so, das ist nicht, ja generell, ja. Ja, können wir gerne machen. Ja, ganz kurz, ich würde kurz einleiten. Aber wir müssen noch bei Friedhof bleiben, Entschuldigung, beerdigen. Ja, genau. Ja, das ist ein Thema, das wird sich durchziehen. Ich habe gerade bei Twitzen, ich habe einen sehr guten Feed gelesen über lustige Beerdigungen. Da hat er immer gesagt, ich möchte irgendwann um fünf Uhr, fünf Uhr in der Früh beerdigt werden, um alle nochmal so richtig abzufacken. Das ist eigentlich eine ganz geile Idee. Das finde ich ganz gut. Habe ich nicht verstanden, aber das finde ich ganz gut. Das könnte auch auf deinem T-Shirt stehen. Überleg uns die ganze Zeit, was auf unserem T-Shirt stehen könnte. Habe ich nicht verstanden, aber fand ich gut. Ich habe einen ganz schönen Tweet zur letzten Folge von Nils, von adhalbaffe. Adhardy.de. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,y.de, at hardy, oh he, uns war der geschrieben, da will man einmal das Podcast-Ufo zum Einschlafen hören und die fangen an, über Geister zu reden. Fand ich sehr lustig, einfach die Vorstellung von jemandem, der sich noch einen schönen Podcast einbauen will und dann fangen wir an, über Geister zu reden, und hat da ganz viel Angst und kann nicht einschlafen, weil wir ein bisschen gruseln, weil wir sind ja auch so ein bisschen so ein grusel-Stau. Ja, spuk euch dran sitzt. Man kann auch ein bisschen Angst haben, dass man da so ein uuuuh. Hast du schon mal einen Geist gesehen? Das weiss ich nicht. Also jedenfalls ist es mir nicht direkt... Hat dich schon mal einen Geist gesehen? Das glaube ich schon. Ja, wahrscheinlich schon. Und wie ist es bei dir, Herr Tietze? Tietze, ne ich habe noch keinen Geist gesehen, glaube ich zumindest. Ich habe gerade einen Tweet rausgehauen, dass die Leute Fragen an so einen Special Guest stellen können. Aber es weiss doch noch niemand, wer unser Special Guest ist. Ne, genau, deswegen habe ich geschrieben unter dem Hashtag Fuck FFAQ Special Guest. Wow, bin ich gespannt. Was finde ich spontan ausgedacht? Da habe ich spontan reingeschrieben. Ich bin ganz stolz auf mich. Du, hau was raus, geil. Darf ich was fragen? Na klar. Warum macht man, warum podcastet man, was ist die Intention? Weil man sich selber sehr geil findet. Ich will anerkennen. Nein, das meine ich jetzt gar nicht. Das ist spontan bei der gleichzeitig Antwort. Wobei die Antwort auch nicht witzig gemeint, aber ich meine es ist mal wirklich, also was ist, weil ich finde es total toll, ich konsumiere es sehr gerne, nicht nur von euch, sondern auch andere, wobei ich sagen muss, ich finde so ziemlich 95% aller anderen, die ich gehört habe, also habe ich da meistens nur einmal gehört und habe es nicht weiter gehört, weil ich es einfach nicht gut finde. Kannst du da mal noch ein bisschen näher drauf eingehen? Ja, da kann er natürlich auch bei der Aufnahmequalität angefangen und sich auch immer über eigene Witze totlachen, das mich total bescheuert. Ja, aber man muss schon, also wir haben auch immer lachen über andere Witze, weil wenn ich jetzt nicht lache, zum Beispiel kann es sein, dass andere sagen, oh Gott, das war ein schön awkward moment zwischen den beiden, aber wenn man lacht, klingt das immer so, als ob man sich selber abfeiert. Ich glaube, es muss auch so ein bisschen eine gesunde Mischung sein. Es macht auch ein gutes Gefühl. Für eine Podcastaufnahme ist ja tatsächlich gar nicht so die eigene Fähigkeit wichtig, sondern die Stimmung tatsächlich. Ich glaube, das ist ähnlich wie beim Sport oder auch wenn man andere Sachen macht. Ich glaube, es ist 80 Prozent körperliche Leistung und Training, aber die letzten 20 Prozent sind dann auch immer noch, hat man gerade Bock drauf, ist man in der richtigen Stimmung. Und so ist es tatsächlich beim Podcast auch. Und wenn man über den Witz lacht, dann ist es eine ganz andere Stimmung. Und der andere hat ein viel besseres Gefühl und weiss, okay, cool, man kommt eher in den Flow rein. Wo ist dann tatsächlich wahnsinnig viel Gelände? Aber was war denn euer Moment, dass ihr gesagt habt, so ey, lass uns doch mal das Podcast-Ufo machen. Also aus was kam das? Ich glaube, Florentins Idee war das, weil er einfach mal irgendwann gehört hat, dass man Podcasts aus dem... Wahnsinnig viel Geld hat mit diesem Parties-Abo. Ich habe, das ist mittlerweile, glaube ich, das ist mittlerweile mein vierter Podcast, ich mache schon relativ lange Podcasts und ich habe früher halt immer Podcasts gehört einfach und habe mir irgendwann gedacht, also das kann ich auch, was glaube ich so ein bisschen der Grundstein von fast jeder Karriere ist eigentlich, zu sagen, hey, das kann ich auch, da habe ich eigentlich Bock drauf, das mache ich und es macht einfach einfach Spaß irgendwie, ich mache, ich höre sehr gerne meine eigene Stimme, ich höre, ich mache, es ist wirklich so, ich mache, ich mache das gerne, ich unterhalte mich gerne. Ihr hört auch nur einen Podcast, sondern das ist mein eigener. Nein, aber so ist es doch wirklich. Jetzt hör mir auf, als ob du dich nicht gerne selber singen wolltest. Nein, natürlich nicht! Ich meinte, wir haben hier Olli-Päzen. Nein, bei mir auch nicht so. Ich höre doch nicht meine Freak. Du bist ein scheiß Freak. Dass man hier einfach mal nicht ein bisschen ehrlich sein kann. Man hört sich oder guckt sich doch da nicht seine Arbeit an. Man macht die Arbeit, weil man war ja eh dabei, also man hört sich das dann nicht nochmal an. Das muss ich aber auch mal sagen. Also ich höre mich quasi. Ich habe hier nochmal so. Nein, aber es macht erstens einfach Spaß und wir wollen natürlich ins Fernsehen, wir wollen zu Tele 5 und haben gesagt, das ist eine gute Möglichkeit da einzusteigen, dass wir da mal ein bisschen Erfahrung sammeln, um da reinzukommen, weil wir sind ja zwar absolute Medienfreaks eigentlich, wie wir beschäftigen sind. Woll ihr wirklich zu Tele5, wollt ihr das wirklich machen? Ja, wir wollen zu Tele5. Wir kennen Tele5 privates nicht, aber wir glauben, dass es... Peter Rütten, wer kann euch da sehr gut weiterhelfen? Peter Rütten, wenn du jetzt zuhörst, beurteile uns bitte an den nächsten zehn Minuten, hör dir nur die nächsten zehn Minuten an, die werden der Knaller, hör sie dir an. Wie würden der Knaller werden, denn es ist noch keine keine Frage eingegangen. Beerdigung hatten wir tot. Es ist, ja, wir haben uns alle coolen Themen eigentlich schon, alle kommende Themen aus dem Abgang. Spammer kommt aus den Augen, Augensäcke sind wie hohen. Gags, äh, Beerdigung, Penislänge haben wir schon tatsächlich besprochen. Wie lange müssen wir noch? Ja, so 20 Minuten. Das ist die Frage, die wir uns ganz aufstellen, wir haben eine halbe Stunde geredet. Na ja. Ja. Wir haben auch Fragen aufgeschrieben. Ah nee. Wir haben auch keine guten Fragen. Jetzt probiere ich ja auch, euch die Fragen zu stellen, damit das auch da rumkommt. Wir haben wirklich keine guten Fragen auf. Nee, Oli P, wie geht's dir denn so? Mir geht's sehr gut, danke. Also was treibst du so? Ach, du Privatier, hat irgendjemand sein Handy an die ganze Zeit eigentlich? Das war von denen Mail. Aber hast du wirklich so viel Geld verdient, dass du jetzt einen langen Latz machen kannst? Jo. Das ist ja geil. Das ist ja richtig geil. Das ist auch so eine ehrliche Antwort, die man sich als Journalist irgendwie auch nicht wünscht. Aber es ist ein Gespräch einfach vorbei. Habe ich mir vorhin auch überlegt, weil jeder im deutschen Fernsehen oder Radio sagt immer so, nein, naja, und ich muss immer noch... Aber dann wird es interessant, dann wird das Gespräch ja interessant. Genau, aber wenn du einfach so, alles gut, ich mache das auch viel interessanter. Nein, wenn jemand sagt, ja, ist das Ziel aber erreicht und das Gespräch ist einfach vorbei. Das Gespräch ist einfach vorbei. Wenn Edward Snowden in diesem langen Interview einfach nur die Wahrheit gesagt hätte, wäre das noch fünf Minuten vorbei gewesen. Aber so ziemlich alle Sachen sind so, dass man eigentlich, ja, aber Leute wollen ja immer einen Hype um einen machen oder einen Kult um einen machen. Beruflich mache ich folgendes, ich habe mit meiner Frau zusammen seit drei Jahren einen Hundeladen in Köln, wo wir frisches Fleisch und frische Ernährungsberatung für Hunde und Katzenhalter anbieten, also sogenanntes Barfen, biologisch artgerechtes rohes Füttern. Gibt es Mango-Konfekt für Hunde? Nein, also bis jetzt noch nicht, aber es ist eine gute Idee. Das ist eine sehr gute Idee, Stefan trademark. Aber was hier drin wäre, könnte man es fast, glaube ich, sogar geben. Stimmt es, dass Hunde keine Schokolade essen dürfen, sondern ansonsten explodieren? Nein, die explodieren nicht, die sterben einfach. Ja, beides glaube ich. Also sie sterben anhand der Explosion. Sterben eher, so explodieren dann. Genau, was ist denn da eine Schokolade? Nein, was ist denn da eine Schokolade? Nein, also man muss sich immer nur überlegen, was es in der Natur gibt und was sie in der Natur essen könnten. Meiner Meinung nach liegt in der Natur zum Beispiel, natürlich wenn sie jetzt in einen Süßigkeitenladen gehen, liegt da Schokolade rum, Aber wenn jetzt ein Wolfsrudel oder Hunde im Wald leben würden, wäre da jetzt normalerweise kein raffinierter oder industriell bearbeiteter Zucker oder Kakaobohn oder sonst was da. Oder eine Frisbee wäre auch nicht da, deswegen kannst du auch einfach mit dem Stock spielen. Aber wenn der Hund ein Frisbee fängt, will er die dann fressen und kann nur nicht oder checkt er schon, dass das jetzt nichts zu essen ist? Der weiss schon, dass das nichts zu essen ist, er weiss aber, wenn du ihn da konditionierst, dass wenn er es dir bringt, dass du ihm dann ein Leckerli gibst. Aber dieses Wiederbringen, was Hunde ja immer machen, woher kommt das? Kommt das aus der Steinzeit? Ich weiss nicht, ob das aus der Steinzeit kommt, aber generell dieses Apportieren, die Jagdhunde mit allen drum und dran, wenn die sich was schnappen und dann zum Rudel bringen oder finden oder erstmal in Sicherheit bringen. Das ist, glaube ich, so ein ganz normaler Instinkt einfach.
Kommen wir wieder zur Hundeernährung.
Also, wie gesagt, man muss halt immer vom Beutetier ausgehen.
Und zum Beispiel ein Kaninchen wäre jetzt ein klassisches Beutetier.
Und es kommt ja im rohen Zustand Lebenfutter.
Es kommt dann aber, wenn es getötet ist, es ist Totfutter, ist aber nicht gebraten, nicht gekocht und wird aber komplett aufgegessen.
Und so muss man sich halt dann das überlegen, was wir bei uns im Laden probieren nachzustellen, woraus ein Beutetier besteht und wie man das mit frischen Zutaten hinbekommt. Aber gibt es dann da auch so Hundegourmets, die dann wahnsinnig tolle Sachen, Nudeln und ganz toll anrichten. Ist es eher Bullshit oder ist es richtig lecker? Meine Meinung nach, Hunde haben sehr viel weniger Schmacksrezeptoren als Menschen und dann ist die Katze nochmal sehr viel drunter und alleine Nudeln macht keinen Sinn, weil...
Katzen sind da drunter? Die wirken wieder total Gourmets gefühlt.
Nee, Katzen gehen nach, ein bisschen nach Geruch, aber gehen nach, wie es sich anfühlt. Also zum Beispiel Katze, es kann sein, dass eine Katze, die Trockenfutter gewohnt ist, wenn du ihr jetzt eine Maus oder einen Fisch gibst, dass sie aufgrund, wie es sich im Mund anfühlt, gar nicht checkt, also es ist was zu essen, sondern es ist irgendwas anderes. Ja, und Nudeln kommen halt so auch nicht in der Natur vor, also ich weiß auch nicht, wie sich ein Hund das jetzt selber kochen sollte. Und schon Nudeln. Aber wo? In alten Mackie-Comics, ja, aber... Man muss sehr sensibel, ich wollte dir sehr sensibel, was Essen angeht. Du kannst ihm das nicht sagen. Ich werde nicht, dass dir meine Kompetenz in das falsche Licht gestellt wird, ehrlich gesagt. Wieso, dass mir das nicht in der Natur vorkommt. Ja, Florian. Bionudeln, hallo? Deswegen heißen die Bionudeln, ja. Und Premium-Futter ist auch Premium, weil ja Premium draufsteht und auf der Verpackung ein Hund im Anzug drauf ist. Aber würden Hunde auch einen Menschen essen? Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass wenn der verwest und der irgendwo rumliegt, dann würden die bestimmt auch … Also sind auch Aasfresser? Es sind Omnivoren, also Aasfresser. Die essen auch ein Aas, also auch was, was ein bisschen länger rumliegt. Wie sieht's denn aus mit Getränken? Also bei Hund denkt man jetzt was … Also Boost trinke ich super gerne. Booster, booster meine ich ja. Boost your energy. Aber wenn man seinem Hund was Gutes tun will, dann denkt man ja meistens eher in der Essensrichtung, so Leckerli, irgendwie mal irgendein Twigs oder sowas.
Wasser ist gut, aber du kannst natürlich auch Smoothies machen, du könntest rein, so kommen die zwar nicht in der Natur vor, aber wenn du...
Oder ein Kaninchen-Smoothie, Kaninchen rein in den Mixer.
Könntest du natürlich auch machen, es kommt jetzt ein bisschen komisch rüber, aber auch das wäre möglich.
Geil.
Obst und Gemüse, wenn du dir selber einen Smoothie machst, kannst du das deinem Hund genauso geben, weil durch das Zerkleinern machst du es eigentlich so, wie es in der Natur vorkommt, weil Obst und Gemüse wird meistens aufgenommen, weil sie den Pflanzenfresser aufessen. Und der Pflanzenfresser, den sie essen, also Kaninchen, hat im Magen schon Verdautes. Und um nachzustellen, dieses Verdautes … What? Die essen den Mageninhalt von Beutetieren? Ist da nicht so Säure drin und so? Das ist das Allererste, was sie essen. Ernsthaft? Weil die Natur sich überlegt, so isst ja jetzt die ganzen Früchte und das Obst und die Nüsse. Also ein Mittelsmann. Genau. Und wenn man jetzt einem Hund eine Karotte so geben würde, unpüriert oder unzerkleinert oder nicht gegart, dann kann man im grossen Geschäft auch wieder Stücke der Karotte sehen. Weil die Natur hat sich eigentlich überlegt, Karotte ist ja eigentlich, weil der Hase die Karotte gegessen hat und ist es vom Mageninhalt so. Das heißt, wenn man seinem Hund was richtig Gutes tun sollte, um auf dein Getränk zurückzukommen, dann mach wirklich aus Obst, Gemüse, mach einen Smoothie, weil dann ist es ganz klein gehackt und viel leichter zu verstoffwechseln. Die fressen den Mageninhalt zuerst? Ja, als erstes, die gehen immer erst auf den Bauch. Mein Gott, jetzt sei doch nicht so... Wie gut ist das denn? Die gehen immer erst auf den Bauch. Das heißt, der Chef isst immer den Bauch. Wenn Kaninchen sind, sind das nur die Mittelmänner quasi.
Kaminchen ist ja noch cool, so ganz das kleiner Kamin. Kaminchen waren kleiner, der nicht eingebaut hat.
Ach so, danke.
Kaninchen, wenn die den Mageninhalt von denen fressen und die quasi nur Früchte essen, damit Hunde das später zerkleinert bekommen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die Kaninchen jetzt Früchte essen, damit Hunde es später essen.
Das ist nämlich deren Platz in der Natur und der ist scheiße.
Und das ist nämlich so, da erkennt man nämlich mal, wo der eigentliche Platz ist von Tieren in der Natur.
Und Kaninchen haben offensichtlich einen scheiß Platz in der Natur.
Zum Beispiel auch irgendwie das gerade leid ein bisschen. So wie Osterhasen eigentlich, die müssen die Eier bringen, können sie auch nicht für sich behalten und werden dann auch noch gefressen. Na Osterhasen haben sich ein Mensch ausgedacht, weil Jesus damals. Jetzt gibt es ja Menschen, die irgendwie zum Beispiel Essen, irgendwie ganz komisch essen, also die dann zum Beispiel so ein Softcake irgendwie dann erst den Rand abknabbern und dann die Schokolade ab. Ja, aber das macht man ja auch, Schnopper ist die ganzen ...
Genau, erst die ganzen Sachen rausknobbeln. Aber das ist doch extra so. Machen Tiere das auch? Ja, halt erst den Bauch. Erst den Bauch, dann die Ohren irgendwie ab, dann die Nasenhaare raus. Ich glaube, da geht es halt danach, was der Rudelführer am liebsten mag. Der isst dann halt die besten Sachen, fängt halt beim Bauch an. Das Alphatier. Das Alphatier, der Chef halt. Und das heisst so, die schielenden Deppen, die kriegen dann so wahrscheinlich ein bisschen was vom Ohr und ein halbes Bein und den Rest müssen sie sich dann sonst wo. Ist denn für den normalen Hund der Mensch das Alphatier? Ja, das merken die auch schon. Also besser gesagt, der Mensch sollte einiges, also sollte alles dafür tun, dass der Hund schon weiss, okay, das ist der Chef, an dem orientiere ich mich, weil Hunde, die das Gefühl nicht haben, kennen wir auch ganz oft, fressen, fressen den Menschen auch. Die fressen entweder die Menschen auch oder bellen halt rum und haben das Gefühl, den Menschen verteidigen zu müssen, weil sie das Gefühl haben, der Mensch ist gar nicht der, der auf mich aufpasst, es muss andersrum gehen. Aber da muss man schon sehr viel falsch machen, man muss sie ja auch anleinen und so, wenn die das Gefühl haben, dass es kein Alphatier ist, was mich gerade anleihen, sondern ein Idiot. Das ist wirklich ein ganz grössten Probleme. Zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt zu Hause bist und dein Hund hört, dass draußen ein Hund bellt, wäre es eigentlich besser, wenn du darauf reagierst und zum Fenster gehst und rausguckst und deinem Hund dann zeigst, ey, es ist alles okay, ich bin hier der Chef. Weil es kann sein, wenn ein Hund so einen Beschützerdrang hat, dass der Hund draußen bellt, du nicht reagierst, weil du ja weisst, hey, der Hund ist draußen, wir sind immer so passiert und der Hund denkt aber, oh mein Gott, bist du bescheuert, Alter, der Feind ist vor der Tür und rastet aus. Also als Tipp würdest du geben, je mehr der Mensch bellt, desto weniger bellt der Hund. Genauso würde ich das gerne als Zitat wie bei Scooter Döp Döp Döp Döp Döp Döp Döp Oli Schulz hat, Oli Schulz hat, Oli Schulz hat gerade in diesem Postkreis gesagt. Ne, Oli Schulz hat schon richtig. Ich habe tatsächlich nach Zitaten von dir gesucht, als Vorbereitung auf dem Podcast. Ich habe keins gefunden. Was soll denn auch für ein Zitat sein? Es gibt keine Zitate von dir. Doch, mein grösstes Zitat ist, der Weg ist das Ziel. Ihr müsst ja mal googlen, ob das schon ... Damit kann mein Navigationssystem immer so wenig anfangen. Ich will es einfach nicht. Das ist ein Kackgag, den solltest du nicht unterbringen. Manchmal ... Ich habe eine App erfunden. Wollt ihr die mit mir machen? Ja, gerne. Wobei, wenn wir es nicht sagen, ist die wahrscheinlich weg, aber ... Mich nervt bei ... Ideen grab Podcast-Ufa, wir haben die Ideen begraben. Eigentlich ist es eine Weltidee, wir müssen jetzt nur schnell sein, also wir nehmen es ja jetzt auf, es wird später ausgestrahlt. Das Patent am Follow- und aufschreibt, darf man es glaube ich nicht mehr klauen. Das ist richtig. Also, die App heißt Statement und ist so etwas wie das Beste aus Facebook und Twitter, zeichentechnisch unbegrenzt.
Es kann aber nur Views geben, also es gibt keine Kommentarscheisse, auch nicht Like, sondern es wird einfach geviewt.
Das heißt, ob das dein Foto ist oder dein Manifest oder sonst was, was du halt sagst, es ist einfach dein Statement.
Und entweder die Leute gucken es oder sie gucken es nicht.
Aber nicht, dass du bei Twitter manchmal das Gefühl hast, das muss ein Facebook-User sein, der gerade hier drauf geantwortet hat, aufgrund der Qualität des Kommentars. Und dass man einfach diese ganze Scheiße umgeht. Aber das will man doch, oder nicht? Man will doch Likes haben. Aber weswegen twitterst du zum Beispiel? Also wir twittern, weil wir Fame-Horse sind, die natürlich die Faves haben wollen. Und wenn wir die nicht haben, dann haben wir tagelang Depressionen. Weil wir auch negatives Feedback haben wollen. Wir wollen wissen, was sind wir als Menschen wert. Das stimmt doch gar nicht. Doch natürlich. Das stimmt überhaupt nicht. Aber bei mir stimmt das absolut. Ihr zwinkert mich gerade an und zeigt auf euer zwinkern das Auge und vor der Hand, die darauf zeigt, ist eine riesen Neon-Reklame, die auch noch klingt. Nein, aber bei mir ist das tatsächlich so. Das stimmt nicht. Doch und klar. Nein. Schau mal, der Mensch jetzt, warum versteht ihr immer noch die Grundzüge der menschlichen Psychologie nicht? Der Mensch will Anerkennung, der Mensch will geliebt werden. Und die moderne Technologie bietet einem Möglichkeiten, das objektiv abzuwenden. Natürlich, das ist das eine wie das andere. Schau mal, was für eine Frau die Blicke sind, die sie in der Fußgängerzone erntet und daran ihr Selbstwertgefühl. Ey, so was sagt man nicht, das ist jetzt schon wieder Sexismus.
Warum denn nicht? Warum ist es Sexismus?
Sexismus. Das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht. Genauso ist es für, kann ja auch Mann sein, ist ja egal.
Sexismus.
Genauso ist es für mich, wenn ich Faves krieg auf meinen Tweets, dann denk ich mir, okay cool, ich hab irgendwas gut gemacht, ich bin wertvoller als Mensch.
Aber wie, wertvoller, wertvoller als?
Als andere, klar.
Ja, natürlich auch wertvoller als, klar.
Florentin.
Hallo, es ist, natürlich, die Gesellschaft ist ein Rodelsystem, natürlich vergleicht man sich mit anderen. Aber ihr seid doch viel, also ich glaube, dass das bei vielen anderen so ist, aber ich glaube, dass das bei euch, dass ihr sehr viel intelligenter seid. Nein, überhaupt, das hat nichts mit Intelligenz zu tun, es hat was damit zu tun, ob man Mensch ist oder nicht. Und jeder, der Mensch ist, will auch Anerkennung haben und will geliebt werden und will Zeichen bekommen, dass er geliebt wird. Es bringt mir aber nichts, wenn mich ganz viele Leute toll finden und es mir nicht zeigen. Warum werde ich jetzt wieder dafür bestraft, dass ich meine innersten Gefühle hier offenbare? Das finde ich unfair, das finde ich keine coole Gesprächsamtunfähigkeit. Finde ich auch scheiße von euch. Wie kommen wir jetzt aus der Nummer raus? Oh, wartet, ich mach mal auf. Ein Special Guest. Noch ein Guest. William! Das ist Thomas D! Die einzige Person, die du imitieren kannst. Nein, Quatsch. Kannst du jemanden imitieren? Das ist auch was, was Deutsche nicht gut können, finde ich. Ich kann eine Katze imitieren, warte. Switch. Das ist sehr gut. Das war eine gute Impression. Danke. Es sind noch keine Fragen angekommen. Ich habe jetzt ein bisschen auf die Leute gehofft, auf Twitter, dass sie uns noch, ich habe auf die gebaut, dass die jetzt irgendwie so Fragen raushauen oder irgendwie sowas. Gut, die wissen zum einen nicht, wer du bist, aber dann haben wir nur ein paar Follower. Obwohl ihr das geschrieben habt, mit Bild und mit Vita. Aber aber auch Sexismus, habt ihr diesen True-Fruits-Skandal mitbekommen? Nein. Nein, gut. Aber wie findet ihr die neue Smileys? Es sind ja neue Smileys rausgekommen. Oh ja, mit den verschiedenen Hautfarben. Also wirklich, also weiß ich nicht, wie jetzt darauf kommt. Ich habe dir vorhin, glaube ich, einen Daumen nach oben geschickt, als du mir die Adresse mitgeteilt hast. Aber welche Hautfarbe hatte der Daumen? Er war schwarz. Aha! Alles schwarz, alles schwarz. Der ganze Daumen war schwarz. Ja. Also ja, es ist tatsächlich ein interessantes Thema. Ich weiß gar nicht, was sie dazu sagen sollen. Ich finde, also mein erster Gedanke war, ich habe Emojis noch nie eine Rasse oder irgendwas zugedingsst. Und seitdem das da ist, finde ich, also jetzt ist es meiner Meinung nach rassistisch geworden. Aber es fällt mir schon auf, also es ist mir nachher alles aufgefallen, wenn ich jetzt ein schwarzer Erdbürger wäre und die ganze Zeit diese weisse Faust gemacht hätte zu Freunden, es wäre mir schon aufgefallen, glaube ich. Und ich kann mir auch schon vorstellen, dass es da Leute gibt, die halt nicht genügend Abstand zu haben, dass sie sich beschwert haben. Und gegen solche Beschwerden bist du nur machtlos einfach als Emoji-Macher. Naja, also ich meine, es gibt ja, egal worin, es gibt ja eine dominierende Kultur. Das ist generell die männliche und es ist generell die westliche. Die englische. Und die englische, so. Das heisst zum Beispiel Dinge wie Salzstreuer ist männlich, einfach weil männlich das dominierende Geschlecht in deutscher Sprache ist. Aber es ist die Türkei. Es ist die Türkei. Das ist mir heute aufgefallen. Das stimmt. Es ist der Balkan und bei Frankreich sagt man wahrscheinlich nur Frankreich, ist das gar nichts? Natürlich gibt es das weibliche männliche Geschlecht, aber zum Beispiel es gibt nur der Salzstreuer. Das männliche ist einfach das neutrale. Und du sagst auch, auch Frauen bezeichnen sich als ich bin Architekt oder ich bin, weil es einfach die männliche. Nein, aber das ist die männliche. Die sagen nicht, ich bin Architekt. Doch, natürlich. Das sagt nicht, ich bin Architektin. Das habe ich schon gehört. Aber es heißt die männlichkeit, das sagt alles aus. Nein, ich will nur sagen, hallo. Stimmt, die männliche, das weiste, mic drop und nicht die männliche. Die Frage ist nur, ob diese Dominanz ein Problem darstellt oder nicht. Ob das einfach eine Notwendigkeit ist, dass man in einer Sprache einfach ein dominierendes Geschlecht braucht, damit es grammatikalisch funktioniert und es ein neutrales gibt, oder hat es tatsächlich Einfluss auf die Personen, die diese Sprache benutzen. Das hat doch wieder eine intellektuelle Frage und überhaupt eine... Ja, aber das ist genau das Gleiche mit den Emojis. Es gibt einfach die dominierende Kultur der Weissen, deswegen sind alle Emojis weiss. Ja, es sind alle Emojis gelb. Gelb, weil die Emojis kommen aus ... Weil Asien die dominierende Kultur ist. So sieht das aus. Und deswegen ist es das Normale. So, und die Frage ist, ist es für einen dunkelhäutigen Menschen ein Problem, dass er nicht normal ist, dass er Normalität nicht mit seiner Hautfarbe repräsentiert ist, oder sieht er das als völlig normales an oder nicht. Zum Beispiel Geister werden immer weich dargestellt. Wobei es wäre schwieriger, sie schwarz darzustellen, weil dann würde man sie nachts nicht sehen. Und vor allem Geister haben immer altmodische Kleidung an. Habt ihr schon mal Geist in einem coolen T-Shirt und Skateboard gesehen? Nein. Oder mit einer Baggy-Jean. Finde ich auch diskriminierend. Das ist interessant. Dann wären sie wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so gruselig. Geister auch sterben. Das ist wahrscheinlich so eine geistige Option. Gut aussehende Geister. Es setzen sich nur die Geister durch. Ich bin es aber auch wirklich verwirrend, dass die Klamotten mitsterben. Also die liegen ja noch irgendwo rum. Das heißt, die gibt es ja zweimal. Ich bin bescheuert. Aber wenn jetzt einer stirbt, dann hat er ja moderne Sachen an. Also wäre er ja ein cool aussehender Geist eigentlich. Ja, eigentlich schon. Oder er kriegt dann Geisterkleidung. Die sind doch nicht mehr so gruselig. Wenn sie tatsächlich in der Kleidung zurückbleibt, dann wird er mit der Kleidung beerdigt. Okay, ich wäre aber nicht mehr, also wenn ich jetzt jemand einem umgedrehter Käppi oder so sehen würde, einen Geist, hätte ich jetzt keine Angst vor ihm. Ich finde es eher cool. Ich finde es cool. Umgedrehtes Käppi. Ja, ist schon ein bisschen angsthaftlösend. Oder ist Rennfahrergeist. Der sitzt dann auch so falsch rum auf dem Stuhl. Ja, genau. Versucht dich zu erschrecken. Und macht Chris-Cross-Moves. Vorgestern bin ich an einer Primark-Filiale vorbeigelaufen. Das ist ein toller Laden. Auch kommen die Potential. Und die Leute haben, und ich habe mich so laut totgelacht und es war mir unangenehm, weil ich habe gemerkt, dass ich ganz alleine unterwegs war und sehr laut gelacht hatte, haben reihenweise ihre Primark-Tüten in ihre H&M-Tüten gestopft draußen und Sachen aus der Tüte in ihren Rucksack gemacht, um die Tüte zu entsorgen. Also gehen rein, nehmen das alles in Kauf, was das darstellt und ist, schämen sich dann aber doch ein bisschen und schmeissen die Tüten weg.
Jetzt meine Idee. Primark gibt einfach weisse Tüten raus. Ich lasse es mal so im Raum stehen. Und zwar von Kindern produziert. Wie geil wäre das? Genau, um die halt auch so ans Arbeitsleben ranzuführen. Ja genau, ich finde auch, man kann auch alles so und so sehen. Also durch Primark ist die Jugendarbeitslosigkeit und Kinderarbeitslosigkeit dermaßen gesunken, die würden alle noch einen Job suchen jetzt, muss man mal so sagen. Satire darf alles, Olli P. Ach ja, Satire darf alles, ja, du hast direkt Satire darf alles. Grinsen dreht er sich vom Mikro weg, Satire darf alles, wir haben alles gesagt. Nein. Ich meine, was würden die Kinder sonst machen, den ganzen Tag Videospiele spielen, Ballerspiele, willst du das wirklich? Nein. Aber ich glaube, das braucht es tatsächlich. Es hat so einen Superspass, die hat jetzt den Tweet favorisiert, was sind eure Fragen an unseren Special Guest. Er beantwortet, er erfüllt einfach den Zweck nicht. Das meine ich mit unserer neuen App, die ihr gar nicht, ihr habt gar nicht gesagt, ob wir die Statement App machen. Die machen wir. Das ist ein geiler Name, einfach Statement. Ja, aber ich will jetzt nicht näher darauf eingehen, sonst klauen die Leute uns die Idee. Ich glaube, der Mensch gibtbt verbotene Dinge. Ich glaube, es ist für Primark marketingtechnisch clever, Primark-Taschen zu verkaufen. Natürlich ist das. Weil der Mensch verbotene Dinge liebt. Er will diese Dinge verboten haben und er liebt es, dann diese Primark-Tasche wegzuschmeißen, weil er sich dafür schämt. Und dadurch bekommt der Primark-Service an sich einen höheren Wert, weil es verbotene Früchte sind. Weil du kannst ja auch einfach sagen, dass der Playboy irgendwie aussieht wie ein Spiegel und dann würden sie mir Leute verkaufen, weil die Leute nicht so eine grosse Hemmung hätten, den zu kaufen, weil man einfach sagt, ich kaufe einen normalen Spiegel und ich gehe mit dem Spiegel aufs Klo kein Problem. Aber ich sage, nein, das stimmt nicht. Ich gehe mit dem Spiegel aufs Klo, sonst lasst man nie wieder so hören wie er. Vor allem, warum sagst du mir das so? Nein, aber ich glaube, der Mensch ... Ich stehe mir gerade die Themen der Sendung vor, wie es ein Profiler mit roten Fäden verbindet, an einer riesen Wand mit Bildern und so. Ich glaube, der Mensch braucht seine Verbote und Tabus, weil er sie geniesst. Ja, so. Beerdigung. Du bist ja sehr moralisch angehaucht. Ja, überhaupt nicht. Na gut, ich hätte dir nicht zugehört, ich wollte irgendwas sagen, ich wollte es gerade irgendwie einordnen. Aber ich finde es bei Florentin immer super, weil er wirklich sich zu sehr, sehr vielen Themen einfach immer wahnsinnig viele Gedanken gemacht hat und sich seinen Standpunkt herausgearbeitet hat und den auch einfach vertritt. Und das finde ich sehr gut. Das ist seine Rolle im Podcast. Das ist doch die einzige Rolle, liebe. Aber ganz kurz, wie oft wirst du erkannt auf der Straße? Also ich muss sagen, da das, also ich bin, ich werde jetzt 37 und ich bin im Fernsehen- oder
Medienbereich seitdem ich 18 Jahre alt bin. So das heisst, das ist jetzt mehr als die Hälfte meines Lebens und du achtest da dann irgendwann nicht mehr drauf, weil es, es gibt bestimmt, also es gibt Menschen, denen es wichtig ist, erkannt zu werden und feiern sich und definieren sich darüber. Soll es auch geben, ist ja auch alles in Ordnung so, aber ich bin mit meinem Leben so wie es ist wahnsinnig zufrieden und lebe in der Welt, in der ich für mich lebe, mit meiner Familie, mit allen drum und dran, bewege mich auch, wenn ich zu Hause bin, immer nur so im Radius von zwei, drei Strassen, weil es da aber auch alles gibt. Und da kennt man die aber auch schon bestimmt. Genau, da wurde ich jetzt aber auch schon seit vielen Jahren, deswegen ist das eher ein ganz normales Miteinander und die Zeiten, wo du 18 warst und jetzt Teenager hinter dir hergerannt sind, das ist ja dann auch vorbei. Aber wie oft wirst du ja noch erkannt? Wie oft probiert? Das interessiert doch auch gar keinen mehr jetzt. So ein tolles Statement interessiert das auch gar keinen mehr. Doch, ich bin Journalist, ich muss da nachhaken. Früher haben die Leute geschrien so, aaaah, Olli, und jetzt kommen sie an und sagen, aaaah, meine Mutter war mal Fan von dir. Ja, aber ich meine, also jetzt nochmal zurück. zurück. Kannst du ein Foto von uns machen vielleicht. Also zurück zu den Likes und Faves. Das sind ja sozusagen Real-Life-Likes und Real-Life-Faves. Es muss ja irgendwo den Moment gegeben haben, wo die abgenommen haben, wo du gemerkt hast, oh, letzten Monat kamen mehr Leute und letzten Monat wieder mehr. Also wie war das? Also zu merken, dass dieser Bogen irgendwann auch wieder nach unten geht. Also dieser, ich denke, das ist ja eigentlich fast bei jedem, der öffentlich arbeitet, so, dann gibt es so einen Anfangsriesen-Hype, gerade im Teenie-Show-Segment. Wir auch gerade. Da ist das, ja, ja, ich habe ja direkt hier auch davor die ganzen Leute gesehen, aber die ersten zwei, drei Jahre ist es immer viel und dann wird es meistens einfach weniger. Das war aber schon nicht immer so. Ir irgendwo den Punkt gegeben haben, wo es immer mehr wurde und dann weniger. Mich interessiert dieser Moment, wo du das erste Mal gemerkt hast, oh ... Das ist investigativ angehaucht. Also ich muss sagen, der erste Moment, wo man einfach gemerkt hatte, es wird ... aber ich habe das nicht als weniger wahrgenommen, aber einfach als, ah, ich kann jetzt mal wieder ins Kino gehen oder ich kann mit meinem Sohn ins Freibad gehen und du wirst nicht dauernd beim Einkaufen beobachtet und heimlich fotografiert. Also es war einfach nur, dass du gemerkt hast, dass deine Lebensqualität einfach wieder sehr viel mehr gestiegen ist. Und auch die Leute aber trotzdem, die ja dann auch mitgewachsen sind, irgendwann auch merken, hey, vielleicht ist es viel respektvoller, nicht zu schreien und umzukippen, sondern einfach Hallo zu sagen und können wir ein Foto machen oder auch nicht. Das ist normal, es sind dem meisten noch die Fans im gleichen Alter und dementsprechend unreifer im Umgang. Aber hier Angela Merkel zum Beispiel, die lebt ja auch im Radius. Das ist genau das, ich bin ja eher der Angela Merkel, das kleine Mann ist. Richtig. Und die geht ja auch immer in den Supermarkt, kann sie auch immer noch gehen, obwohl sie die fucking Bundeskanzlerin ist von Deutschland. Und wahrscheinlich auch, weil sie halt immer noch in ihrem Radius bleibt. Ja, kommen auch immer fünf BND-Agenten mit. Ich glaube, das ist noch ein bisschen was anderes, als wenn Olli P. einkaufen geht. Entschuldigung. Oder die geht doch nicht alleine einkaufen. Klar geht die alleine einkaufen. Ja klar, damit irgend so ein Typ, die zusammenschlagen kann oder was. Ja. Angela Merkel geht hundertprozentig nicht alleine einkaufen. Ich glaube, die kann sich ja selbst verteidigen. Natürlich hat die Sicherheit. Ich glaube, die das Bundeswehr mal irgendwo einkaufen darf. Auf gar keinen Fall. Natürlich mit Personenschützern so dringend. Ja eben, natürlich. Ich meine ja. Oh, ganz kurz. Ich glaube, dass eine Bundeskanzlerin sich auch selbst verteidigen könnte im Zweifelsfall. Na klar. Die kriegt doch Kaffee. Die ist doch bei Agents of Shields. Ja klar, klar. Ja klar, die ist doch bei Kung-Fu, Kung-Fu-Kurse und so. War die nicht auch bei der Stasi oder so? Da hat die bestimmt so ein paar Griffe gelernt. So bam, über die Schulter und so. Also als Bundeskanzlerin kriegt man, glaube ich, auch Kurse, wo man sich selbst verteidigen kann. Guckt ihr Danger Five? Nein. Nee. Aber erklär doch mal, Zusammenfassung kurz. Nö. Hab ich noch nicht gehört von. Nee, okay. Fass doch mal die ersten acht Staffeln einfach mal ersten acht Staffeln einfach mal zusammen. Nun ja, also gut probieren gegen das Böse zu kämpfen. Das Böse entkommt immer durchs Fenster. Ui, ich hab übrigens die ganz Lost, Lost hab ich nicht geguckt, wollte aber irgendwann mitreden können. Schaut euch nicht Lost an, Leute, das wusste ich nicht. Wollte ich mitreden können, hab ich mir die ganze Story, die ganze Handlung auf Wikipedia durchgelassen. Deswegen haben die so viele Staffeln gemacht, weil sie immer wieder probiert haben, es gut zu machen, aber es hat halt acht Staffeln lang nicht geklappt. Ja. Also jetzt entwürdigst du, was man machen kann, eine Staffel oder eine ganze Serie auf die Handlung auf Wikipedia nachlesen, geht gar nicht klar. Furchtbar. Ne, das kann man echt nicht machen. Ne. Kann man echt nicht tun. Wie viele Minuten müssen wir noch? Wir haben in 52 Minuten geredet. Ach ne, wir können noch ein bisschen. Ich finde das ganz interessant. Ich finde Oli P ist ein interessanter Typ eigentlich. Ach, jetzt hör doch mal auf. Oder musst du los, oder was? Naja, ich wollte noch was kochen. Wolltest du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du,. Wie bei Shopping Queen oder sowas, ey war super geil, war so lecker, hat richtig Spaß gehabt und eine gut gemeinte Vier. Das hält es eigentlich bei allen meinen Zeugnissen immer. Herausragende Sprach-Wortschatz-Vier. Dass wie eine Szene gedreht wurde, super, wir machen noch eine. Aber hast du... Da war schon sehr viel Gutes dabei. Aber kommt ja auch manchmal Hass entgegen in der Öffentlichkeit? Weil ich habe ein bisschen gegoogelt, Oli P. als Vorbereitung. Und ich habe eigentlich tatsächlich die ersten zehn Einträge bei Google sind irgendwie Diss auf Hip-Hop.de irgendwie, was will der denn so? Ja, aber das ist ja alles 15 Jahre oder so. Ja, eben, aber ich meine generell irgendwie. Ja, das war früher so, ist ja klar. Also immer wenn du... Gerade die Hip-Hop-Szene ist auch sehr streng damit. Was ja auch sehr mit Popmusik zu tun hat, ist das gleiche, wie wenn sich jetzt Rammstein über Musikantenstadel aufregt. Das hat natürlich, wobei machen sie ja mit Heino, na egal. Nee, aber das ist ja normal, also alle die mal erfolgreich in einer bestimmten Teenie-Genre-Geschichte erfolgreich sind, Also da gibt es auf der einen Seite dann halt drei Millionen, die die Platten kaufen,
es gibt dann aber auch dann andere, die es scheisse finden, merke ich ja auch, also oder ihr wahrscheinlich auch, ihr guckt auch manche Comedians recht gerne, aber es gibt dann auch wahnsinnig viele, die man scheisse findet. Ja, deshalb. Und dann gibt es manche, die sich da artikulieren müssen, und jetzt heutzutage oder seit Internet ist es natürlich noch mal leichter zu sagen, dass man was scheisse findet. Ausser mit Apps wie Statements. Ausser mit Statements. Da kann man, da kann man komisch verweisen. Wobei, da könnten auch alle einfach das Statement machen, dass sie was scheisse finden. Ich würde das gerne weiterentwickeln, Statement mit Kommentiefunkitionen. Aber das hat sich aber sehr, sehr entspannt alles. Ich kann mich jetzt innerhalb der letzten fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn Jahre nicht daran erinnern, dass noch irgendjemand mal blöde war. Das Schöne ist, ich habe bis vor zwei Jahren auch MMA gemacht, also Muay Thai, Bodenkampf, Boxen, Kickboxen, Thai-Boxen. Wie die Kanzlerin. Wie die Kanzlerin? Wir waren ja beide bei Schien damals. Glaubst du, du kannst die Kanzlerin besiegen? Weiß ich nicht. Das organisieren wir alle, oder? Oli P versus ein Lerner Merkel. Celebrity Deathmatch. Geil, das wäre ein super Kampf, glaube ich, da würden die Leute entscheiden. Aber geht's ja, Promiboxen, oder? Bei FIFA, ja. Oli P versus an der Märkte. Celebrity Deathmatch.
Geil!
Das wär ein super Kampf, glaub ich, da würden die Leute einschalten.
Aber geht's ja Promiboxen, na ja, stimmt.
Ja, vielleicht.
Diese Affen vom Provin.
Bist du doch eigentlich ein Promi?
Auf jeden Fall.
Das kannst du niemanden fragen.
Doch, natürlich, ich will wissen, wie ihr es selber einschätzt.
Ach, das ist ja ...
Warum kann man das denn immer fragen?
Das ist so eine Kacke mit deinem Scheiß Verbus und wie da bei mir.
Ich hab so Bock, wenn du in den Rücken zu fallen. Es ist ne, also ich finde, ja, ich habe mehr, ich weiß nicht, es ist natürlich, aber ich will, ne?
Man kann ja nicht darauf ja antworten, ohne unsympathische.
Doch natürlich, ja, genau, das ist es halt, natürlich, aber mir aber natürlich...
Man ist so ein scheiß mit dem Thema aus.
Also man ist schon, also natürlich, ich glaube die Definition prominent oder bekannt oder wenn man heutzutage schon 10.000 Follower hat bei YouTube oder sonst wie, ist man ja auch schon einer bestimmten Zielgruppe bekannt, also ist man ja für die ein Prominenter, das heißt es gibt auch Leute, die vor zehn Leuten auftreten, das sind aber die Hardcore-Fans und auch für die ist er prominent und natürlich wenn du drei Millionen Platten verkauft hast und seit so vielen Jahren Sachen arbeitest und Moderation, natürlich ist man prominent, dann kannst du wieder so A, B, C, D, E, F, G prominent. Da frage ich mich aber auch mal Leute, die normale Jobs haben. Wenn jetzt zum Beispiel ein Kemptner zu mir kommt, ist er dann jetzt für mich nur der F-Kemptner, weil es gibt bestimmt noch bessere Kemptner und auch den Chef von seiner Kemptner Firma. Deswegen finde ich es wieder schade und traurig, dass wir wieder kategorisieren müssen und einstufen müssen. Aber du bist schon ein Dschungelcamp, du bist schon ein Dschungelcamp berühmt, oder? Was? Du bist schon ein Dschungcamp berühmt, also man könnte dich einladen. Also jeder Bundesbürger ist Dschungelprominent, weil ja auch Normalbürger, die nicht prominent sind, auch eingeladen werden. Wurde du schon mal für das Dschungelcamp angefragt? Ich wurde am Anfang angefragt, bis ich mal gesagt habe, dass es sehr freundlich ist, aber solange ich Familie und Freunde habe, würde sowas nicht stattfinden. Wie viele hättest du gekriegt? Hm? Wie viele hättest du gekriegt? Das weiss ich nicht. Okay. Nochmal zum Thema ausgesorgt. Das ist doch so ein Urlaub, wo man Erfahrungen an seine Grenzen zu stossen, um mal so ein bisschen auszutesten. Wo ich mich dann mal frage, ja dann mach doch Urlaub im Dschungel alleine, dann fahr doch da hin und teste das mal aus. Ne, das ist interessant, also ich glaube, weil Dschungelcamp setzt ja schon so eine gewisse Prominentengrenze fest. Also es gibt ja niemanden, der sagt...
Ja, das heißt, Prominentengrenze ist, du musst schon einmal mit einem Prominenten geschlafen haben.
Ja, und wenn es das ist?
Und das habe ich noch nicht.
Okay.
Ja, aber so ist es halt auch.
Klar, natürlich, habe ich.
Aber ich meine, es gibt ja gewisse Regeln, weil man Prominent ist.
Es ist halt so wie früher der Adel einfach.
Das war halt eine objektive Sache.
Der gehört zum Adel und der nicht.
Und so ist es halt Prominent heute.
Wenn man eine Autogrammkarte hat, dann ist man Prominent, die man sich ganz günstig 2000 Stück bei Flyer, 60 Euro bestellt. Ja, Flyer-Alarm. Nochmal ganz kurz zum Thema ausgesorgt. Hast du damals, als du richtig viel Geld verdient hast, schon angefangen, früh was zur Seite zu legen und so, oder hast du einfach so wahnsinnig viel verdient, dass du das gar nicht musstest und es trotzdem noch genug hast? Beides. Das ist beides. Das ist gut, dass ich durch mein privates Umfeld, durch meinen Vater und ja, also immer sehr familiär gewunden war und wir auch einfach aus einem normalen, wie sagt man immer, bürgerlich Mittelstand, sagt man sowas immer?
Ja, Grossbürgertum.
Grossgrundbesitzertum, dass ich eigentlich sehr normal aufgewachsen bin und auch nie probiert habe, anders zu leben. Also ich habe nie gesagt, jetzt muss ich mir aber das Hochhaus mit dem Hubschrauber kaufen, sondern es hat einfach die Villa mit dem Hubschrauber gereicht. Ja, aber es ist eigentlich so ein bisschen der Traum von jedem Menschen eigentlich, so ein bisschen so viel Geld zu haben, dass man nicht mehr arbeiten muss. Wie viel Geld ist, also wir sind ja noch relativ jung, du auch noch, wie viel Geld müssten wir jetzt haben, um nie mehr arbeiten zu müssen? Kommt drauf an, wo du lebst und wie du lebst. Ja genau, was für ein Leben ist. Sagen wir mal hier. Und ich will jeden Monat 3000 Euro haben. Das kannst du dir doch hochrechnen, die 3000 Euro auf die Jahre, wo du denkst, dass du noch lebst. Aber wie ist das denn, tatsächlich diesen Status erreicht zu haben? Ist es so geil, wie man denkt, dass es ist, oder ist es eher lebt? Natürlich, du hast ja eine Sicherheit im Hinterkopf, also das ist ja schon mal ganz gut, dass du nicht, also der Druck ist auf jeden Fall insofern weg, aber auf der anderen Seite ist es ja auch, hat es trotzdem nichts damit zu tun, dass man nicht denkt, dass man eine Aufgabe haben muss, weil ich glaube, es wäre sehr, sehr doof, wenn man sagt, so ich habe jetzt ausgesorgt und ich setze mich jetzt an den Strand. Ich glaube, dass das bestimmt spätestens nach einer Woche echt langweilig wird oder zwei Wochen oder drei. Ja, mit coolen Leuten, sehr guten Bitches, glaube ich, ist das was. Na gut, ja, das ist wieder was anderes. Du kannst jetzt bessere Bitches leisten auf jeden Fall. Ist das ein Qualitätsum? Das weiß ich nicht, das musst du die Bitches fragen. Wir haben... Ja, du, Chantal, dass er eine mitgebracht hat, sei nicht. Wir haben nur hier, also das ist kein Problem. Ne, ist interessant, wir haben noch nie mit dem Prominenten gesprochen. Ich habe bewusst noch nie mit dem Prominenten gesprochen. Ihr seid doch selber Prominenten. Ich bin unfassbar nervös. Also man stellt sich das immer so toll vor, aber man denkt sich natürlich auch irgendwie, weil man macht ja vieles einfach nur für Geld, also dieser Podcast würde nicht existieren, wenn nicht, sag ich mal, das eine oder andere monetäre Interesse ausgesprochen hätte. Ich muss sagen, dass ich sehr viele Sachen, die ich mache, und das ist aber für mich immer, das sind immer so Themen, weil es halt schon sehr privat ist, aber da wir hier sehr privat sind, und da hat ja kaum jemand zu. Nee, einfach das, was wollte ich denn gerade sagen? Ich wollte irgendwas sagen. Ach, das ist egal. Mit Arbeit. Ach, Scheitern. Nee, einfach wahnsinnig viele Sachen dann auch einfach gerne mache. Es gibt bald jetzt auch noch ein anderes TV-Comedy-Format. Wo? Auf Tele5? Nee, auf einem privatsender, auf einem öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender, aber ich bin ein riesen Fan davon und für mich war es einfach ganz, ganz toll, da beisein zu dürfen. Und da geht es dann gar nicht darum, dass man jetzt eine Gage kassiert, sondern dass man sagt, ey, das ist total cool, dabei sein zu dürfen. Also ich finde, jedenfalls in der Medienwelt, vielleicht auch sonst wie, es gibt immer eine Sache, da musst du mit deinem Brötchen verdienen oder halt gucken, dass alles gut ist. Dschungelcamp. Und wenn du, ja genau, und dann gibt es aber auch Sachen, die musst du machen für dein Herz, falls es so sein sollte, dass die Arbeit dich nicht so sehr... Leider ist es sehr oft so, dass das, was man gerne macht, halt kein Geld abwirft. Genau, aber man soll es ja trotzdem machen. Deswegen auch Leute, die dann sagen, ja, Musik und ich will... Ja, weil du genau die gegenteilige Erfahrung machst. Aber die Leute, die Musikstars werden wollen und zu Castingsendern gehen, versteht man ja, aber wenn sie wirklich gerne und gut singen, das kann man ja auch so machen. Man kann eine Band machen, man kann in der Kneipe gehen und da auch singen. Also wenn es einem wirklich nur um die Sache an sich geht, die einen glücklich macht, dann brauchst du nicht damit unbedingt jetzt Geld zu fangen. So eine Sonja Zidlow zum Beispiel, der kaufe ich nämlich total ab, dass sie das, was sie macht, total feiert, dass sie das, was sie macht, total geil findet. Und wenn es gleichzeitig auch nur das ist, wofür du halt Geld bekommst, viel Geld bekommst, weil du kriegst ja bei LT immer mehr als bei ZDF Neo, dann ist es ja geil, dann hast du ja gewonnen quasi. Also du kannst mit einer Lebenseinstellung, wenn du von Geburt an so eine Lebenseinstellung mitbekommen hast, dass das, was du da machst geil ist, ist wirklich voll. Ich finde einfach, das Allerwichtigste im Leben ist, dass man, und das ist auch so abgedroschen, genau wie der Weg ist, das Ziel, aber auch dieses, dass man einfach in den Spiegel gucken kann und dass man mit sich selbst im Reinen ist.
Ist dir das gelungen? Kannst du wirklich auf deine Karriere zurückschauen und sagen, alles was ich gemacht habe, da steht voll dahinter? Ja, weil ich weiss, dass ich, also was heisst, ich weiss, ich weiss ja nur, dass alles was ich gearbeitet habe und gemacht habe, dazu beigetragen hat, dass ich jetzt so bin, wie ich jetzt bin. Und ich bin, muss ich sagen, ich bin ziemlich ...
Ziemlich cooler Typ.
Sie sind ein ziemlich geiler Typ, die wissen, Sie ist ziemlich geil aus, muss man mal sagen. Du hast einen geilen Jutebeutel, bringt geile Sachen mit. Dein Lifestyle ist der Hammer. Nein, also ich bin glücklich mit meinem Leben und mir fehlt nichts. Ich bin einfach, also so wie es ist, kann es gerne noch 50 Jahre bleiben. Und wenn ich, wie gesagt, ich weiss ja nicht, dass wenn ich was anders gemacht hätte, ob jetzt irgendwas irgendwie anders geworden wäre, von daher bereue ich nichts, weil es scheint ja alles, für mich hat alles gepasst und ich mache ja nicht die Karriere oder ich mache ja die Arbeit nicht, damit andere das gut finden, weil ich mache das ja nur für mich. Bei euch ist es ja, bei Florentin ist es ja, dass halt die Leiche kommt. Ja genau, lass mich daraus, ich bin da voll... Deswegen machen wir, Stefan und ich, die Statement-App ohne diese Geschichten. Genau, genau. Ich mache die Stat. Mhm, ja. Ich mach die Statement-App, einigungs darauf, mit Kommentarfunktionen. Also Facebook. Das ist doch scheinbar. Nein, einfach Facebook. Nein, das ist doch kacke. Ich glaub, das kommt gut an. Nein, ohne Hashtag-Schrott. Auch dieses Hashtag, hat sich das überhaupt durchgesetzt? Also ich meine, schreiben Leute wirklich unter diesem Hashtag dann extra Sachen und gehen da rein, oder ist Hashtag nur da, dass man Archivgründen. Archivgründen, ja. Aus Archivgründen. Damit die Historiker in 200 Jahren mal gucken können. Das ist gut. Was da passiert eigentlich. Ey, das ist übrigens... Apropos Historiker, dein Alien-Witz war der lustigste auf Twitter, muss ich sagen. Oh, dankeschön. Geht da nochmal näher drauf ein. Also, du hast... Jetzt muss ich ihn nochmal wieder zusammenkriegen. Oh, hier. Zwei Fanboys hätten aufeinander. Du hast gesagt, ein Saxophon-Spieler hat mit offenen Augen Saxophon gespielt, liebe Aliens, da müsst ihr irgendwie beim nächsten Mal doch euch ein bisschen besser bemühen.
Sehr gut. Jetzt natürlich in 440 Zeichen und sehr viel knackiger und besser erzählt von dir, aber das fand ich sehr, sehr witzig und ich weiss aber, das war wieder ein Moment, wo ich gelacht hätte und hätte ich das einigen Leuten, die ich kenne, auch gezeigt, hätten sie mich angeguckt und wären weitergegangen.
Ja, kenn ich. Aber bist du ein Historyak? Bist du ein Geschichtsfreak? Ähm, ja, also ich gucke mir gerne halt so History-Sachen von Ulf Kotter an, ne, weil da lernt man halt auch noch ein bisschen. Aber in hundert Jahren Historiker, die über diese Zeit schreiben müssen, die haben es doch super einfach. Weil sie leben im Internet und finden Dinge. Ja, aber das Internet gibt es dann nicht mehr vielleicht. Vielleicht gibt es ein anderes Dateiformat. Aber du hast ja eine Million unverifizierter Quellen. Ich glaube, andere Geschichtsschreiber, dann gab es halt das eine Buch und die eine Aufzeichnung von damals. Das war es heutzutage. Aber man hätte damals auch unter Briefe Hitler schreiben können. Ja, aber ich meine, es gibt ja Cyberkriege. Wer weiß dann da noch, was jetzt wirklich... Ich meine, es wird ja Cyberkriege geben. Und genauso wie damals Städte und ganze Landstriche verwüstet wurden, werden jetzt halt Rechenzentren und Informatik-Datenzentren verwüstet. Wenn irgendwie mal ein Land ... Schau mal, stell dir mal 100 Jahre vor, ein Land wie China, was die für eine fucking Hacker-Power haben und einfach mal sagen, okay, gut, wir rotten einfach mal Deutschland aus. Die hacken dich kaputt von vorne bis hinten, die hacken jedes kleine lokale Bürgeramt-Büro. Es geht auch auch wieder zur kleine Stadt am See. Ich glaube auch, dass Großstädte, wenn die sowieso sehr viel gesündert, wenn das alles nicht mehr da wäre und alle wieder so hundert Mann wohnen. Ja, bis zum See und hast kein WLAN. Viel Spaß. Ja, das WLAN ist das Real Life. Ich habe mal geschrieben, das WLAN ist das neue Licht. Also überall wo WLAN ist, sind mittlerweile schon so Gruppen, kleine Gruppen, die sich in diesem WLAN... Das ist das, so alle schaden sich in das WLAN. Es ist wie Mottenfliegendes Licht, Menschen fliegen zum WLAN. Ja, die gucken, wenn du noch einen Balken hast, stellt sich ja auch auf den Tisch und guckst noch irgendwas zu machen. Es ist wie Internet, Leute sammeln sich im Internet. Wenn du irgendwo eine Wüste hättest und du hättest an ein paar Stellen Internet verbunden, wären die da. Wenn das Wasser woanders wäre, wäre es scheißegal, Hauptsache Internet. Ist Real Life für Ingame-Versager? Ja, und andersrum. Da muss ich sehr lange drüber nachdenken. Ich glaube, es gab tatsächlich mal die technische Idee, dass man Lichtquellen mit WLAN-Quellen verbindet, damit überall wo Licht, dass man es direkt ans Lichtsystem einspeist. Das ist praktischer, es verbindet halt. Ja, aber das Problem ist, wenn du es halt ein Handy in der Hosentasche hast, dann kommt halt kein Licht durch. Deswegen müssen alle durchsichtige Kleidung tragen. Und dann, dann kommt ein neuester, der der menschlichen Evolution bricht dann an. Oder, also ich mein, glaubst du ... Nee, Quatsch, natürlich wird's immer Kleidung geben. Ich war gar nicht gefragt, ob wir irgendwann einfach keine Kleidung mehr tragen. Weil wir irgendwie alles in uns eingebaut haben. Früher haben die heute wesentlich mehr an. Mittlerweile ... Aber ist doch lustig, wenn man sich jetzt Filme anguckt, ich hab mir neulich letzte Woche Blade Runner von 79 angeguckt, und es gibt auch noch andere Filme, als dieme. Okay, wir können schon auch über einzelne Filme lesen, das ist okay. Aber Blade Runner zum Beispiel, auch alles, was da Videotelefonie, wahrscheinlich als sie es damals gedreht hatten, dachten sie, oh mein Gott, wir sind so krass, wir tun so als ob wir jetzt und es ist halt für jeden und jetzt auch die ganzen Livestream-Apps, Mehrkett und so und Per, weiß ich, ich weiß halt noch nicht so richtig den Sinn und Zweck. Stimmt. Wir hätten mir ketten können, wir sind Idioten. Die nächste Folge vielleicht. Aber es wäre immer noch die Dokumentation aus der Vergangenheit, die die Zukunft widerspiegeln wollen. Also es gibt zum Beispiel aus 1974 oder so gibt es eine Dokumentation im ZDF, wie die sich damals die Zukunft vorgestellt haben. Und wenn man sich das heute anguckt, ist es einfach total lustig anzusehen, wie die halt mit ihren begrenzten Mitteln versucht haben, sich die Zukunft vorzustellen. Aber viele technische Sachen sind ja dann wirklich sehr... Ja, aber die haben halt nur, die haben halt, wenn die neue Fernseher zeigen wollen, haben die halt ihren alten Röhrenfernseher genommen und den halt Silber angemalt, weil es einfach eine Zukunftsfarbe ist. Es ist ja eigentlich per Definition relativ unmöglich, die Zukunft darzustellen. Es ist unmöglich, es ist unmöglich. Es ist ja ein sehr ambitiatives Unterfangen. Also Leute, es sei denn, man hat einen DeLorean und reist in die Zukunft.
Das habt ihr mal wieder vergessen.
Wollen wir noch mal ganz kurz, dass ich euch zeige, dass einen Stern, der meinen Namen trägt oder deinen Namen trägt, dass das die Medieführung von Albano und Ruh...
Ja, das machen wir noch. Musikanalyse.
Warte, ich spiele ganz kurz den Jingle ein.
Ja.
Achtung, jetzt kommt unsere Rubrik, Rubrik die Musikanalyse.
Die Musikanalyse.
Und diese Woche beschäftigen wir uns mit dem Thema Ein Stern.
Der Künstler, die Olimp hat uns ein kleines Referat vorbereitet. Viel Spaß dabei. Gleich kommt's, am Anfang ist es noch nicht. Ist es noch nicht am Anfang? Und der nächste ist es. Ein Stern. Ach du Schande. Hört es sich so an? Es ist die erste Investigativgeschichte in diesem Podcast. Hört es sich so an? Das ist ein Glück. Das ist ein Glückwunsch. Was machen wir jetzt? Was ist der nächste Schritt? Wir behalten es für uns. Wir waren noch nie so weit. Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leuteste ... Ja, weg mit den Stein. Nein, nein, nein, wir machen Schal mit Taschen, damit man Sachen in seinen Schal stecken kann. Ja, okay. Wir verkaufen diesen Beitrag am Monitor, weil ich glaube, das ist ein Riesending. Blurred Lines wurde geklaut, da ist Milliardenbanner drin. Ja, aber Robin Thicke hat ja auch ein Hashtag, wir brauchen erstmal ein Hashtag. Hashtag ... Ähm, ein Stern, der einen anderen Namen trägt. Ist zu lang. Ist zu lang. Zu lang, wir machen Hashtag P für Has P für Hashtag Podcast UFO. Ich war heute bei einer Beerdigung. Hashtag P für das Podcast UFO, damit wir unsere Ideen weiter verteilen können. Olli, was ich noch fragen wollte. Also jetzt, wenn man so, du bist ja Privatier, du hast ja ausgesorgt. Also gibt es dann auch so, sag ich mal, kulturelle Projekte, die man sich vornimmt. Jetzt mal zu sagen, so ich fange jetzt an zu malen. Ich habe einen Garten. Ich habe einen Garten. Ja, und meine Idee ist, ich will innerhalb der nächsten zwei Jahre, wenn mein Sohn sein Abitur fertig hat, möchte ich auf jeden Fall. Viel Erfolg? Wie alt ist sein Sohn? Vierzehn. Wie alt wird er sein, wenn er in zwei Jahren sein Abitur macht? Scheissidiot. Vierunddreissig. So, sechzehneinhalb. So, und ich will auf jeden Fall dann nochmal in eine andere Stadt ziehen, als in der ich jetzt gerade wohne. In welcher Stadt? Weiss ich noch nicht. Mich interessiert das in der Sohn vielmehr. Nein, ich will einen, ich will unbedingt einen. Alle gute Noten. Meine Sohn hat mal von dir eine reinbekommen in einem Einspielerdreh, aus Versehen. What? Okay, red weiter. Ja, okay. Was? In einem Einspielerdreh? Ach du Schande, das ist ja geil. Das war der oder? Das war mein Sohn, genau, der eine Polizist, aber egal. So, und was hat er für der Cast? Hat er für der Cast? Wir hatten selber Arbeit. Hört doch mal zu. Okay, okay, erzähl erst mal, erzähl erst mal. Ich will einen, also mein Ziel, und das meine ich wirklich im Ernst, momentan kann auch sein, dass es später mal anders ist, aber ich würde gerne so eine Art, und das meine ich wirklich, auch wenn ihr jetzt gleich darüber lachen werdet, einen Gnadenhof aufmachen, wo du halt einfach Tiere aufnimmst und einfach denen ein gutes Leben bereitest. Und das finde ich einen schönen Inhalt und deswegen möchte ich das machen. Nee, das ist doch gut. Warum haben denn Tiere ein gutes Leben verdient? Weil sie keine Scheisse machen. Warum haben nicht... Weil sie nicht lügen, sie nehmen dich so wie du bist. Jetzt kommt man das an, dass das Torschlag am Ende ist. Das ist doch irisch. Sollte man sich erst mal um die Menschen kümmern, denen es schlecht geht? Ja, nee. Ist nicht meine Meinung, es ist eine Stimme des Volkes.
Aber die Menschen haben, glaube ich, schon ziemlich oft einen Schuss vom Bug bekommen,
haben so viel Scheisse schon gebaut und immer wenn du denkst, jetzt läuft es auch schon viel Scheisse gebaut.
Tiere haben auch schon ein bisschen Scheisse gebaut.
Ich meine, das Trojanische Pferd, das Trojanische Pferd, das hat ultra viel Scheisse gebaut.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Es hat einfach ...
Garfield, Garfield zum Beispiel, die Chipmunks, das HB-Männchen. Und ich meine, die Menschen haben nicht die Dinosaurier ausgerottet. Just saying. Ja, aber auch der Dinosaurier hat den Dinosaurier nicht ausgerottet. Ich glaube, es war ein Meteor. Das wissen wir nicht mehr, das ist nur deine Meinung. Doch, doch, da waren auch schon die Säugetiere mit im Spielodo. Ja. Der Dodo-Fisch, da waren die Menschen noch nicht da.
Achäoptrix.
99 % aller Spezies, die es jemals gab, sind ausgestorben.
Ja.
Davon haben die Menschen vielleicht, sagen wir mal, 80 %, ja, aber die restlichen 29.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass eine andere Spezies so viel von ihrer eigenen Spezies kaputt gemacht hat.
Kannibalismus, drittes von Kannibalismus.
Ja.
In weitestem Sinne, Kriege, Mohrorde. Ja, Das machen jetzt Tiere nicht so in so einem Umfang, glaube ich. Zitat, Olli Schulz. Ich sag, so muss sie mal in anderen. Es gibt, glaube ich, nur so eine Gorilla-Geschichte, wo die so ihr alles so verteidigt. Jetzt ist meine gute Frage, du bist ja sehr tierlieb, hier höre ich ja so ein bisschen im Subtext raus. Jetzt folgende Situation.
Schafe-Deduktion, Sherlock-Sellerbefehl.
Folgende Situation passiert. Du gehst spazieren, du hast dein iPhone in der Hand, hörst irgendwelche lustigen Soundeffekte an, spazierst du an einem See entlang, du siehst einige Enten, ja, ein paar Eichhörnchen, vielleicht ein kleiner Fuchs steckt vielleicht seine Schnauze kurz hinter einem Baum hervor und sagt hallo. Jetzt passiert folgende Situation, du siehst ganz viele Enten, die plötzlich angeflogen kommen, auf einen Punkt in der Wiese und dort anfangen Radau zu machen. Du läufst hin und siehst, das sind ganz viele Erpel, die gerade eine Ente vergewaltigen. 20 Erpel, eine Ente vergewaltigen. Das Wort Erpel ist ein sehr tolles Wort. Ich hoffe, dass das so wie Füsse geblutet wird. Füsse geblutet. Vergewaltigt. Du guckst hin, Erpel vergewaltigt. Die Ente wird vergewaltigt. So, hast du jetzt eine moralische Verpflichtung, der Ente zu helfen oder nicht? Ich glaube, das würde ich spontan entscheiden. lässt man der Natur seinen Lauf. So funktioniert Moral nicht, meine ich. Doch, aber... Nein, Olli Schulz, Olli Schulz, so funktioniert Moral nicht. Das ist der grosse Satz von Immanuel... Ach so! So funktioniert Moral nicht, Olli, du kannst nicht sagen spontan, nein, das ist unmoralisch. Ja, ich kenne den Satz von Kant, verfick nochmal. Der grosse Satz von Kant ist, muss ich spontan entscheiden, muss ich spontan entscheiden, ist der grosse Satz. Nein, es ist genau nicht, Kant sagt genau das Gegenteil, Kant sagt, dass Moral objektiv ist, verdammt nochmal. Meine subjektive Empfindung generell ist so, dass ich denke, alles was die Tiere machen, ist schon immer richtig so und alles was die Menschen machen ist immer... Ist der Menschlich auch ein Tier? Nein. Gut. So. Einfache Frage, einfache Antwort, mein Gott, kann man doch mal mal ein. Das ist der Kühlschrank, ich auch ein Flugzeug. Also es ist, also ich glaube, Tiere machen alles aus dem Instinkt und das wird schon immer seine Richtigkeit haben, jedenfalls mehr als bei Menschen, weil Menschen ganz anders, glaube ich, berechnen. Aber die Ente leidet doch genauso. Es macht doch keinen Unterschied, ob jetzt ein Mensch auf die Ente eintritt oder Erpel auf die Ente eintritt. Die Ente leidet und darum geht's doch. Das ist doch Sympathie mit dem Wesen. Ich glaube, dass Beispiel ein bisschen... Ich glaube auch nicht, dass viele Erpel eine Ente wäre gewaltig. Doch, das ist so passiert, da habe ich Quellen dafür. Ja, genau. Nein, ich würde natürlich der Ente helfen. Der grosse Erpelanfall von 1993. Von Ulaanbatu, damals das Erpel-Massaker. Nein, also ich finde es natürlich generell nicht gut, dass irgendwas kaputt gemacht wird oder tot gemacht wird. Auf der anderen Seite finde ich es ja dann, deswegen bin ich ja da auch noch in so einem Prozess, natürlich esse ich dann auch Fleisch, ne, dann weiß ich aber auch, dass da ein Tier gelitten hat. Ich glaube, ich wäre gerne Vegetarier, aber da bin ich halt so im Kontext. Aber du isst doch auch eher Fleisch aus Käfig-Haltung, weil du sagst, die hat ein Scheißleben, die haben sich auf die Axt gefreut, die haben gesagt, mich bitte zuerst, Freunde, die waren froh, dass sie tot sind. Das ist doch, oder? Nein, nein, nein, nein, genau das ist das Gegenteil. Aber ist es nicht total lame, dass die Tiere ein gutes Leben haben, um dann am Ende getötet zu werden? Die raffen das doch, die sind doch nicht doof, die wissen doch, warum sie in dem Käfig sind. Glaubst du nicht, dass sie die Frage stellen, äh, pass mal auf, aber jetzt kurz, also zum Beispiel Hühner leben, zum Beispiel, die haben ja auch zwei Tage an einem Tag, also den Tag benötigt er nur zwölf Stunden, damit die zwei Eier legen. Ist halt so, da wird halt das Licht ausgemacht. Die kennen ja kein anderes Leben. Also ich habe immer das Gefühl, generell ist das alles scheisse. Klar, klar, das ist total scheisse, aber die kennen das ja nur. Ja, aber es ist ja gesellschaftsfähiger. Ich glaube, ich akzeptiere es so, wie wenn man jetzt wieder dann mit ein paar Leuten an einem Teich wohnen würde und dann muss man irgendwie überleben.
Und dann ist man Sachen... Müsst du den ganzen Tag Enten vergewaltigen?
Nee, man isst ja dann einfach Sachen, um zu überleben. Ob es jetzt Getreide ist, was ich ja auch weglasse, oder andere Sachen, kann natürlich dann auch mal ein Tier sein, was man dann jagt und dann ist es halt so. Aber was der Mensch daraus gemacht hat und was ja trotzdem einfach nur wirtschaftlich und industriell gesteuert ist, ist halt trotzdem moralisch, finde ich, trotzdem sehr fragwürdig, weil es einfach auch nicht gesund ist für den Planeten und für alles. Jetzt sagen alle, ihr müsst Bio kaufen, aber so viel Bio, wie jetzt gerade verkauft wird für so viele Milliarden weltweit, so viel Bio kann es gar nicht geben. Da wird auch saufel Geld gemacht, ne? Da wird auch saufel Geld gemacht, glaube ich. Ich habe keine kleinerlei Stütze dafür, ich habe einfach mal jetzt irgendwie radikal... Das ist ja auch mal was, Lieferheld.de. Lieferheld ist super geil. Gibt es da auch schon Bio? Nein. Das wäre was, komm, wir machen eine Statement-App. Man kann bei Lieferheld, ja genau, aber Lieferheld, wo man Trinkgeld eingeben kann. Also wo man Leute... Das ist immer doof, das muss man einfach dem so in die Hand drücken. Ja, mache ich auch dann manchmal, wenn ich daran denke und ich genug Geld habe, aber sonst, also bei Pizza.de kann man zum Beispiel... Kommt eigentlich noch, also hast du noch mal da bestellt? Nee, da habe ich mich nie mehr getraut. Hast du dich bei PayPal mal beschwert für die Sanktionen? Nee, nein, habe ich nicht mehr beschwert. Aber ich bin so ein Schisser, so ein Riesenschisser, der dann einfach sagt, okay, lassen wir uns jetzt einfach ruhen und ich mache das nie wieder da. Angenommen, du läufst mit deinem Hund den See entlang und dein Hund greift jetzt die Ente an und will sich vergewaltigen, Greifst du dann ein? Natürlich. Warum? Warum macht das einen Unterschied? Nein, ich würde auch bei den anderen Sachen eingreifen und das nicht zu, dass das passiert. Du würdest eingreifen? Ich würde immer eingreifen. Was ist, wenn es jetzt keine Ente ist, sondern Wurm? Ich glaube, es wäre anatomisch nicht möglich, dass Erbel einen Wurm vergewaltigen. Vor allem zu viele. So, das probieren wir jetzt aus. Ronny, bring mal die Ente rein! Chantal, komm mal jetzt noch mal rein! Bring mal die Wurmer! Einen grösseren Maßstab, geht das aber auch schon. Ich glaube, wir kommen da nicht weiter, vielleicht können wir da auch einfach die Leute die Follower fragen. Was ist das komplexeste Tier, das du jetzt auf der Stelle töten würdest? Das komplexeste Tier, das ich töten würde? Aber ich will doch gar kein Tier töten.
Also aber angenommen, hier ist es eine Regenbogen. Die erste Frage. Darf er sie seinen Namen verraten? Nein.
Es sind echt wahnsinnig schlechte Follower, die wir da haben, die auch ganz komische Fragen stellen.
Wie lange machen wir denn jetzt eigentlich noch? Wenn du nicht auf meine Fragen antwortest, dann können wir es noch lassen.
Tja, dann... Warte, ich glaube, ich habe noch eine Frage. Ich will noch kurz eine Frage stellen. War das der, die macht das auch mal. Dad dadurch wird's ja auch tiefer. Ich raste aus. Halt, stopp! Ich hab nämlich die Aufnahme gesehen von diesem riesen Brass-Orchester, wie die diese Score aufgenommen haben. Das sind tolle Dokumentationen drüber. Ja, aber von der Melodie her, vielleicht. Ich rudere zurück. Du müsstest jetzt noch zweimal nachhaken, und ich Ich gebe komplett auf. Zweimal nachfragen und ich gebe auf. Nun ja, wer nicht aufgegeben hat, ist tatsächlich Oliver Mark Walter Pezzucat. Vielen Dank, dass du heute hier warst. Vielen Dank, unser erster Stargast tatsächlich. Und dann fangen wir direkt mit der Creme der Creme an. Du bist der entspannteste Prominente Deutschlands. Der was? Der entspannteste oder der entspannteste? Der entspannteste. Ach schade. Wir müssen noch kurz auf dem Teppich bleiben. Na gut. In dem Moment erscheint eine Sonnenbrille in deinem Gesicht und die Musik erscheint. Yeah. Ah, ah, ah. Also danke, dass ich da sein durfte bei euch hier heute im Podcast-Fofo. Freestyle, wir sollten noch freestylen. Das hatte ich ja schon mal gemacht und ich finde, äh, wie deinen ... Bei deinen Erbeln.
Genau, bei deinen Erbeln.
Schuster bleibt bei deinen ...
Olli P, vielen Dank, dass du da warst, dankeschön.
Mein Jingle noch, zum Rausgehen, habt ihr noch einen, habt ihr noch einen.
Vielen Dank, das war Olli P, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das Podcast Sufo hebt ab.